Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. Come all ye rebels, youth spirits, rock minstrels, truth seekers, peacock freaks, poets, barricade jumpers, dancers, lovers, artists. It is summer, it is the last week in August and the National Death Party meets the Blessed Johnson. We are there. There are 500,000 of us dancing in the streets, throbbing with amplifiers and harmony.
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。每周获取独家加更节目、无广告收听、系列节目抢先体验，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区的会员资格，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。来吧，所有叛逆者、年轻的灵魂、摇滚歌手、真理追寻者、孔雀怪咖、诗人、街头筑垒者、舞者、恋者、艺术家。这是夏天，这是八月的最后一周，国家死亡党遇到了保佑约翰逊。我们在那里。有五十万人走上街头跳舞，伴随着扩音器和和声的震颤。
We are making love in the parks. We are reading, singing, laughing, printing newspapers, groping, and making a mock convention and celebrating the birth of free America. The life of the American spirit is being torn asunder by the forces of violence, decay, and the napalm cancer fiend. We demand the politics of ecstasy. We will create our own reality. We are free America and we will not accept the false theatre of the death convention. We will be in Chicago. Begin preparations now. Chicago is yours. Do it.
我们在公园里做爱。我们在阅读、唱歌、大笑、印报纸、调情、举办滑稽大会，庆祝自由美利坚的诞生。美国精神的生命正被暴力、腐烂以及凝固汽油弹恶魔的力量撕成碎片。我们要狂喜的政治。我们要创造自己的现实。我们是自由的美利坚，我们绝不接受死亡大会的虚假戏剧。我们将出现在芝加哥。现在就开始准备。芝加哥属于你们。干吧。
So that Dominic, I mean, you'll recognize this because these are very much your people, aren't they? These are the Yippies, the youth international party. And that was their manifesto which was published in early 1968. Yeah. And the National Death Party, that's the Democrats, the Yippies are preparing to go and make their case for how America should be run. They are. On the very doorstep of the National Death Party as it meets for its convention in Chicago. Nothing better captures, I think Tom, the tone of the late 60s counterculture than that very powerful and persuasive manifesto. I'm gonna be
所以多米尼克，我的意思是，你会认出这一点，因为这些非常符合你们这群人的风格，不是吗？这些就是嬉皮士，青年国际党。这就是他们在1968年初发表的宣言。是的。而国家死亡党，那是民主党人，嬉皮士们正准备去为美国应该如何治理阐明他们的主张。他们的确去了。就在国家死亡党齐聚芝加哥召开大会的门口。我想没有什么比那份强有力的、极具说服力的宣言更能捕捉到60年代末反主流文化的基调了。我得
honest, I love the Yippies. Do you? Yeah. So what's coming today is one of the most dramatic weeks in modern American political history. It's the Democratic National Convention in Chicago, where as you say the Yippies are going to confront the war makers, the man with the politics, not merely of protest, but the politics of play as they would call it and a massive spoiler alert for anybody who doesn't know what's coming. This will not end well at all for anybody. It all kicks off, doesn't it?
老实说，我爱死嬉皮士了。是吗？对。所以接下来要发生的是现代美国政治史上最戏剧性的几周之一。这就是在芝加哥举行的民主党全国代表大会，正如你所说，嬉皮士们将去对抗战争制造者，那些玩弄政治的人——不仅仅是抗议的政治，而是他们所谓的游戏的政治——对于任何不知道接下来会发生什么的人，这里有个巨大的剧透。这对任何人来说都不会有好结果。一切都要开场了，不是吗？
It does indeed kick off. So this is one of the most turbulent political set pieces in American history. The televised pictures of riot police, the Chicago police, battling protesters right underneath the hotel where the democratic bigwigs have their campaign headquarters. I mean, it's an extraordinary, extraordinary moment, but we've got the yippies to come Tom, so restrain yourself. I know you love the yippies. By the way, I will just say the one thing, which is that everybody who's listening to the podcast, not watching us on YouTube, you merely heard that, but I had to see, I mean, you really performed that, didn't you? There was a lot of gurning, wasn't there?
确实要开场了。所以这是美国历史上最动荡的政治重头戏之一。电视画面上，防暴警察，芝加哥警察，正在民主党大员们设立竞选总部的大酒店下方与抗议者搏斗。我的意思是，这是一个非同寻常的时刻，但我们还有嬉皮士要聊，汤姆，所以克制一下。我知道你爱死嬉皮士了。顺便说一句，我要说的是，所有听播客而不是在 YouTube 上看我们的人，你刚才只是听到了，但我不得不亲眼目睹——我的意思是，你刚才真的表演出来了，对吧？有很多挤眉弄眼，不是吗？
There was a lot of gurning. Well, I was entering into the fun. Yeah, the absolute spirit of it. And I think, you know, that you've missed your calling in many ways. I like to think that you can smell the Josticks as I was saying that. I think ultimately the dynamic of this podcast is basically on the one hand, somebody who could well have been in the Yippies and on the other hand, somebody who would have very much enjoyed being part of Mayor Daley's Chicago police department.
有很多挤眉弄眼。好吧，我是融入了那种乐趣。是的，完全是那种精神。我想，你知道的，你在很多方面都大材小用了。我想象着你说话时能闻到檀香的味道。我认为归根结底，这个播客的动态基本上是一方面有一个很可能是嬉皮士的人，另一方面有一个非常乐意成为市长戴利芝加哥警察局一员的人。
The pigs. And there are more pigs to come. And I'll leave it to the listeners to work out which is which. So let's remind ourselves where we got to with the Democrats. President Lyndon Johnson had pulled out of the race on the 31st of March and that left three candidates. Eugene McCarthy, the giant killer who had kind of toppled him. Vice President Hubert Humphrey and the romantic celebrity par excellence Robert Kennedy.
那些猪猡。还有更多猪猡要登场。我留给听众去分辨谁是谁了。所以让我们回想一下我们对民主党的了解。总统林登·约翰逊在3月31日退出了竞选，这留下了三位候选人。尤金·麦卡锡，那个击倒他的巨人杀手；副总统于贝尔·汉弗莱；以及无可匹敌的浪漫名人罗伯特·肯尼迪。
McCarthy and Kennedy, you'll remember, fought out the primaries. Kennedy won narrowly in California on the 4th of June and was assassinated in his moment of victory. So you might think, just picking up that story, well, does this leave McCarthy free, unchallenged, as the standard bearer of the anti-war movement against Hubert Humphrey? But actually not really. First of all, the Kennedy people still, you know, are very bitter about McCarthy. standard bearer of the anti-war movement against Hubert Humphrey. But actually not really. First of all, the Kennedy people still, you know, are very bitter about McCarthy.
你们会记得，麦卡锡和肯尼迪在初选中一决高下。肯尼迪在6月4日的加利福尼亚州险胜，却在胜利的时刻遭到暗杀。所以你可能会想，接着这个故事往下想，这难道不是让麦卡锡作为反战运动的旗手，在对阵于贝尔·汉弗莱时变得自由、不受挑战吗？但实际上并非如此。首先，肯尼迪的人仍然（你知道的）对麦卡锡怀恨在心。反战运动对抗于贝尔·汉弗莱的旗手。但其实并非如此。首先，肯尼迪的人仍然（你知道的）对麦卡锡怀恨在心。
McCarthy himself spends the next two months in what I think was ultimately a kind of deep depression. Does he feel guilty then? I think he does feel guilty. So if you remember in the last episode, he had made quite sardonic, you might say insensitive remarks immediately on hearing that Kennedy had been shot. But then I think he did feel guilty, you know, when I did my book on McCarthy. People I interviewed said he just seemed a stricken man in the next two months.
麦卡锡自己在接下来的两个月里陷入了我认为最终是一种深度的抑郁之中。那他感到内疚吗？我想他是感到内疚的。所以如果你还记得上一集，他在刚听到肯尼迪被枪击的消息时，曾做出过相当讽刺、甚至可以说是不近人情的评论。但随后我想他确实感到内疚了，你知道的，当我写关于麦卡锡的书时。我采访的人说，在接下来的两个月里，他看起来就像一个受打击的人。
He was disengaged from his campaign. Actually there's a note in Hubert Humphrey's archives. McCarthy went to visit Humphrey the day after Kennedy died and Hubert Humphrey made a secret note of the conversation. And he said he felt that McCarthy was just completely exhausted, had lost heart, all of the fun had gone out a bit for him. And his campaign basically falls apart. There's a wonderful line, and I think it's in American melodrama where the
他不再参与竞选活动。实际上于贝尔·汉弗莱的档案里有一份记录。肯尼迪死后的第二天，麦卡锡去拜访了汉弗莱，于贝尔·汉弗莱对这次谈话做了一份秘密记录。他说他觉得麦卡锡完全精疲力竭，已经失去了信心，对他来说所有的乐趣都消失了。他的竞选活动基本上分崩离析了。有一句精彩的话，我想它出自在《美国情节剧》中，
British, it's a very British comparison. They say of McCarthy's campaign,, degenerated into a cross between a girl's boarding school and an Oriental court. Yeah, that is a very British comparison. Which is a very British comparison. So his marriage is kind of breaking down under the strain of the campaign, things aren't good for McCarthy. So this leaves Humphrey really, it's very clear by midsummer that he's going
英国人，这是一个非常英国式的比较。他们说麦卡锡的竞选活动退化成了“女子寄宿学校和东方宫廷的结合体”。是的，这确实是一个非常英国式的比较。这也是一个非常英国式的比较。所以他的婚姻在竞选的压力下有点破裂了，麦卡锡的日子不好过。这实际上留下了汉弗莱，到仲夏时分，很明显他将
to be nominated by the Democrats. And to remind ourselves who he is, because he's a kind of presence offstage throughout this story. He's the former mayor in Minneapolis. He was an absolute liberal titan in the Senate. He was key in passing loads of civil rights legislation, but he has been Lyndon Johnson's eunuch since 1964 and has sort of turned himself into a very implausible defender of the president's Vietnam War policy.
被民主党提名。为了提醒我们他是谁，因为他在整个故事中一直是一个幕后存在。他是明尼阿波利斯的前市长。他是参议院里绝对的自由派泰斗。他在通过大量民权立法方面发挥了关键作用，但自1964年以来，他一直是林登·约翰逊的男宠，某种程度上把自己变成了一位总统越南战争政策的极其牵强的辩护者。
Well, he hates it, doesn't he? Secretly. He feels bound by loyalty to stand up for it. So it's a horrible position for him to be in. He's in a terrible position. And the thing is that makes it such a terrible thing is that in many ways Humphrey is such a likable person. He's very optimistic.
好吧，他私下里恨透了，不是吗？他出于忠诚感而觉得有义务站出来支持它。所以对他的处境来说这太可怕了。他处境糟糕。问题在于，使之如此糟糕的是，在许多方面，汉弗莱是一个非常讨人喜欢的人。他非常乐观。
He's very cheerful. He's very earnest. He's quite uncool by late 60s standards. He's like the protagonist of a 1950s American sitcom, isn't he? Yeah, very much. Yeah. He's quite Dickensian. I think he could be like a Mr. Cheerable or something. Big jolly man. He's jolly, he's kind-hearted, he's a do-gooder, he's a philanthropist kind of character, all of that kind of thing. It was later said of him that he was forced onto the party by the corrupt party bosses. That's not really true. He is the party favourite.
他非常快乐。他非常认真。按照60年代末的标准，他相当不酷。他就像1950年代美国情景喜剧的主角，不是吗？是的，非常像。是的。他相当有狄更斯风格。我觉得他就像欢乐先生之类的人物。一个快乐的大块头。他很乐观，心地善良，是个行善者，带点慈善家的性格，诸如此类。后来有人说他是被腐败的党内大佬强加给党的。这其实并不是真的。他是党内的热门人选。
The polls always show that most rank and file Democrats actually really liked Humphrey. And he's very popular with the unions, isn't he? And he's very popular with the trade unions and the city bosses because he's been there for so long and he's great at kind of firing up a crowd and he understands the kind of bread and butter issues that Democrats have always wanted. But unfortunately, in the climate of 1968, he's not groovy. He's not groovy at all. So he is probably going to be nominated in Chicago. Now let's talk about Chicago. Chicago is at this point, the second biggest city in the United States.
民调总是显示，大多数普通民主党人其实真的很喜欢汉弗莱。而且他在工会中很受欢迎，对吧？他在工会和城市大佬中非常受欢迎，因为他资历深厚，而且他擅长点燃人群的热情，他理解民主党人一直想要的那些基本生计问题。但不幸的是，在1968年的氛围下，他一点也不时髦。他一点也不时髦。所以他很可能会在芝加哥被提名。现在我们来谈谈芝加哥。芝加哥此时是美国第二大城市。
It hasn't yet been overtaken by Los Angeles. It's the capital of the Midwest and its reputation is the city that works. So it's always compared with New York. Chicago is a much more well-oiled machine than New York. Its finances are in better shape. It's not crippled by strikes all the time as New York is. It's a very inadvertent comment, it's ethnic to use the terminology of the 60s and 70s. it's a very ethnic city. So Irish, Eastern European, Italian, and so on. And black? And it does have a large black population. However, it's by far the most segregated city in the United States, meaning there are black neighborhoods and there are white neighborhoods and there's not
它还没有被洛杉矶超越。它是中西部的首都，它的声誉是“运转正常的城市”。所以它总是被拿来和纽约作比较。芝加哥比纽约是一个运转更良好的机器。它的财政状况更好。它不像纽约那样总是瘫痪于罢工。这是一个非常无意的评价，用60年代和70年代的术语来说，它是一个非常有族群特色的城市。也就是说爱尔兰人、东欧人、意大利人等等。还有黑人？它的确有很大的人口黑人群体。然而，它是美国种族隔离最严重的城市，这意味着有黑人社区，也有白人社区，而且并没有
really a huge amount of mixing. But obviously not legally. Exactly. De facto rather than de jure. not really a huge amount of mixing. But obviously not legally. Exactly, de facto rather than de jure. So when Martin Luther King had gone to Chicago in 1966 to try and urge kind of housing integration, he had been really shocked by the hostility in Chicago and he had said this is worse than
真正大量的融合。但显然不是法律上的。没错。是事实上的，而不是法律上的。并没有真正大量的融合。但显然不是法律上的。没错，是事实上的，而不是法律上的。所以当马丁·路德·金在1966年去芝加哥试图推动住房一体化时，他被芝加哥的敌意深深地震惊了，他说这比南方任何地方
anything in the South. Now all of this is controlled by one man, Mayor Richard J. Daley. He's going to dominate this story in many ways. He is the Democratic Party in Chicago. He's from a working class Southside Irish neighborhood. His father was a sheet metal worker. His mother was a Catholic Church volunteer. He'd worked his way up the Democratic Party ladder.
都要糟糕。现在这一切都由一个人控制，那就是理查德·J·戴利市长。他在许多方面都将主导这个故事。他就是芝加哥的民主党。他来自南区一个工人阶级的爱尔兰人社区。他的父亲是一名钣金工人。他的母亲是天主教会的志愿者。他通过民主党内的阶梯一步步爬了上来。
He's a bright boy. He's very ambitious. He's a hard-nosed operator. And in 1955, he had become mayor and he controlled everything in the city. He's one of the last of the great big city American men. He's a man for whom the word boss is basically made. Totally, exactly. He is the quintessential boss daily. Boss daily, city boss. He controls every job, every elected official. Does he smoke fat cigars?
他是个聪明的孩子。他很有野心。他是个强硬的操盘手。1955年，他成为了市长，并控制了这座城市的一切。他是伟大的美国城市大佬中的最后几位之一。他就是为“大佬”这个词而生的人。完全正确，毫无疑问。他就是典型的戴利大佬。戴利大佬，城市大佬。他控制着每一份工作、每一位当选官员。他抽雪茄吗？
Massive, I would imagine. Yeah. I mean, he basically looks like a cigar. He's like a walking cigar, but he's the working man's friend, right? So ever since the New Deal, when federal money has come into Chicago, it's Mayor Daley who basically dispenses it to working class neighbourhoods. And presumably to organisations that are chiefly staffed by working class people, including the police. Exactly. So exactly. Now to high minded people, outsiders, they regard him, especially in the climate of the late sixties, as an anachronistic and ultimately both sinister and comical person. So Norman Mailer in his book, Miami in the Seeds of Chicago, which is a brilliant book about the
巨大支的，我想。是的。我的意思是，他基本上长得就像一支雪茄。他就像一支会走路的雪茄，但他也是工人的朋友，对吧？所以自从新政以来，当联邦资金流入芝加哥时，基本上都是戴利市长把它分配给工人阶级社区的。想必也分配给那些主要由工人阶级员工组成的机构，包括警察局。完全正确。所以，没错。现在，对于那些思想高尚的人、局外人来说，他们认为他——尤其是在六十年代末的氛围下——是一个不合时宜的、最终既阴险又滑稽的人。所以诺曼·梅勒在他的书《迈阿密与芝加哥的种子》中——这是一本关于那一年的代表大会的精彩著作——他对戴利做出这样的评价：戴利看起来像一个极其健壮的老农妇，戴着一顶脏兮兮的灰色丝质假发。
conventions of that year, he says of Daley, Daley looked like a vastly robust old peasant woman with a dirty grey silk wig. Good description. Which is not entirely untrue, it has to be said. So Daley had lobbied very hard for the convention to come to Chicago. He wanted it for prestige, he wanted it for the $30 million that it would bring into the sort of Chicago tourist industry, and he's very close to Lyndon Johnson. So he has benefited from the Great Society and all the federal funds coming in. Like Johnson, he's a hawk on Vietnam. He talked to Lyndon Johnson's biographer, Carl Orton.
好描述。这也不完全是假的，必须得承认这一点。所以戴利曾极力游说将代表大会开到芝加哥。他为了声望而想要它，为了它将给芝加哥旅游业带来的3000万美元而想要它，而且他和林登·约翰逊非常亲近。因此他受益于伟大社会和所有涌入的联邦资金。和约翰逊一样，他是越战鹰派。他跟林登·约翰逊的传记作家卡尔·奥顿交谈过。
Daley probably talked to Johnson 15 times in the first few months of 1968. Daley was horrified when Johnson withdrew. And Daley is thinking that since the convention is in his city and he will have a lot of control over it, maybe he can use it to get Johnson to reconsider. Right. And get the convention to draft Johnson in as a candidate, even though Johnson has supposedly withdrawn.
在1968年的头几个月里，戴利可能跟约翰逊谈过15次话。当约翰逊退选时，戴利惊呆了。戴利在想，既然代表大会在他的城市举行，而且他将对其有很大的控制权，也许他可以利用这一点让约翰逊重新考虑。没错。并让代表大会推举约翰逊作为候选人，尽管约翰逊据说已经退选了。
And is that because there's a political alignment or is it the kind of fact that they're quite temperamentally quite similar political figures? I think a bit of both actually. I think they're both alignment or is it the kind of fact that they're quite temperamentally quite similar political figures? I think a bit of both actually. I think they're both at this point on the kind of hawkish wing of the Democratic Party, but I think temperamentally they're both kind of, you know, cigar chomping bullies, even though Johnson has given up smoking. They are big men, burly men. They like nothing better than sitting up late at night with a bottle of scotch and laughing at fae, foppish students and all this kind of thing.
这是因为政治立场一致，还是因为他们在性格上是非常相似的政治人物？我觉得两者都有吧。我觉得他们俩政治立场一致，还是因为他们在性格上是非常相似的政治人物？我觉得两者都有吧。我觉得他们俩此时都属于民主党内的鹰派，但在性格上，他们俩都有点像（你知道的）咬着雪茄的恶霸，尽管约翰逊已经戒烟了。他们都是大块头，身材魁梧。他们最喜欢的事莫过于深夜坐在一起，喝着一瓶苏格兰威士忌，嘲笑那些娘娘腔的、矫揉造作的学生以及诸如此类的事情。
Neither of them are really fans of hippies. Not at all. I think it's fair to say Matt Daly is not at all a fan of hippies. Now by early 68, it's obvious there are going to be protests at Daly's convention. So the most prominent peace group is a group called the National Mobilisation Committee to End the War in Vietnam, which is better known as the MOBE, a very late 60s abbreviation. And the MOBE is really quite religious, kind of born out of Catholic and Quaker peace groups. I was going to say, I mean, it is a kind of late 60s name, but the tone of it is kind
他们俩都不是嬉皮士的真正粉丝。一点也不是。我觉得可以公平地说，马特·戴利绝对不是嬉皮士的粉丝。到了68年初，很明显戴利的大会将会面临抗议。所以最突出的和平组织是一个叫做“结束越南战争全国动员委员会”的组织，更广为人知的名字是 MOBE，一个非常具有60年代末风格的简称。而 MOBE 实际上相当具有宗教色彩，某种程度上源自天主教和贵格会的和平组织。我本来想说，我的意思是，这确实是一个60年代末的名字，但它的基调
of more earnest. It's almost the kind of stuff that George name, but the tone of it is kind of more earnest. It's almost the kind of stuff that George Orwell was mocking as prune juice drinkers and all that kind of thing. Because the guy who's it's guiding spirit, Dave Dellinger, I mean, he's a very Orwell figure, isn't he? He actually, I think he drove an ambulance in the Spanish civil war and he was a conscientious objector in the second world war and he brings a whiff of the forties and fifties.
更偏向于严肃。它几乎就是乔治·奥威尔嘲颂的那种喝西梅汁的人以及诸如此类的事物。因为它的精神领袖戴夫·德林格，我的意思是，他是一个非常具有奥威尔色彩的人物，不是吗？事实上，我想他曾在西班牙内战中开过救护车，并且是第二次世界大战中的兵役拒服者，他带来了一股四十和五十年代的气息。
He does indeed. He's from a Protestant background, pacifist background. As you say, conscientious objector in the second world war, being around peace groups all his life, absolutely has that kind of mid-century earnest improving quality. So slightly out of kilter, I think, with the more ludic atmosphere of the late sixties and Dellinger wanted to get a hundred thousand people to Chicago to, as he put it, confront the war makers. The interesting thing here is of course there are two conventions that year. So the Republicans meeting in Miami, but it never occurs to them to go to Miami because it's the Democrats who draw their
他的确如此。他出身于新教背景、和平主义背景。正如你所说，他是第二次世界大战中的兵役拒服者，一生都在和平组织中，绝对具有那种世纪中叶的严肃改良品质。所以，我认为它与六十年代末更具嬉戏氛围的时期有点脱节，德林格想把十万人带到芝加哥，正如他所说的那样，“去对抗战争制造者”。这里有趣的地方在于，那一年当然有两个代表大会。共和党人在迈阿密开会，但他们从来没想过去迈阿密，因为是民主党人吸引了他们的
eye. I think for two reasons, one, obviously the Democrats are in power, but two is there is something more offensive about the people who are supposedly meant to be on your side. So it's very much, I think, reminiscent of the protests against Joe Biden and Kamala Harris this year. About Gaza. About the Gaza, exactly. That the IRA is directed at them and not at kind of Donald Trump and the Republicans. Anyway, now the Moab have a rival. There's another group that are planning to go to Chicago and this is the group that
目光。我认为有两个原因，第一，显然民主党人在台上，第二是那些本该和你站在同一边的人，身上有一种更具冒犯性的东西。所以这非常让人想起今年针对乔·拜登和卡玛拉·哈里斯的抗议活动。关于加沙。关于加沙，没错。矛头是针对他们的，而不是针对唐纳德·特朗普和共和党人。不管怎样，现在 Moab 有了一个竞争对手。还有另一个组织正计划去芝加哥，这就是那个
produced that lovely manifesto that you began with. The Yippies. And these are the Yippies. produced that lovely manifesto that you began with. The Yippies. And these are the Yippies. So the two big guys in the Yippies are Abbie Hoffman and Jerry Rubin. They're both activists from Jewish backgrounds. They had been to university.
制作了你开篇提到的那份可爱宣言的组织。嬉皮士。这些就是嬉皮士。制作了你开篇提到的那份可爱宣言的组织。嬉皮士。这就是这些嬉皮士。所以嬉皮士里的大佬是阿比·霍夫曼和杰里·鲁宾。他们都是犹太背景的活动家。他们都上过大学。
Hoffman had been a student activist and a civil rights activist. Rubin had started a sociology PhD at Berkeley. I mean the thing about Hoffman particularly and why he's such a contrast to Dellinger is that he absolutely gets the technology that is available to him. So he's always doing stunts like kind of burning money on TV and things, isn't he? Yes. And he has this famous line that a modern revolutionary should head for the television studio, not for the factory. And that's basically what he's all about. Happenings, sit-ins, all this kind
霍夫曼曾是一名学生活动家和民权活动家。鲁宾曾在伯克利攻读社会学博士学位。我的意思是，尤其是霍夫曼，以及为什么他与德林格形成如此鲜明的对比，在于他完全抓住了可供他利用的技术。所以他总是搞一些恶作剧，比如在电视上烧钱之类的事情，不是吗？是的。他有一句名言：现代革命者应该去电视台，而不是去工厂。这基本上就是他的全部主张。事件、静坐抗议，所有这些
of stuff, you need to get on the television. And of course, that is a lesson that he will have picked up from Martin Luther King. I guess so, yeah. The civil rights movement was all about getting on TV to some degree. Yes. Staging public spectaculars in which you are the martyrs and the victims. The mobilised people behind your cause. I mean, that is the essence of Martin Luther King's strategy, I guess. Yeah. And because in 67, so the Summer of Love, it's Hoffman basically who invents the look of the hippie, doesn't he? Because he has this group called the Flower Brigade. And he's the one who says, you know, put on the flowered clothing and the bell
东西，你得上电视。当然，这是他从马丁·路德·金那里学到的一课。我想是的，没错。民权运动在某种程度上全都是为了上电视。是的。上演公众大戏，而你们是殉道者和受害者。动员人们站在你们的事业背后。我的意思是，这大概就是马丁·路德·金策略的精髓所在。是的。因为在67年，也就是爱之夏，基本上是霍夫曼发明了嬉皮士的外表，不是吗？因为他有一个叫花朵旅的组织。他是那个说（你知道的）穿上印花的衣服、喇叭
bottom jeans and the headbands and the beads, the classic hippie look. And it's designed to aggravate the police basically, kind of squares. Yes, it's designed to be a very stark contrast with the war makers, the pigs, the military industrial complex, all of that kind of thing. So the classic image of people putting flowers in the barrels of guns is a very kind of Hoffman Rubin kind of image. These guys had worked together on the march on the Pentagon in October 1967, and they had led this huge protest in the centre of Washington DC. They had gone on this march to the Pentagon and they had chanted songs and tried to exorcise it and to levitate the Pentagon. Now obviously
裤、发带和珠子的人，这就是经典的嬉皮士造型。这基本上是为了激怒警察，也就是那些保守正统的人。是的，这旨在与战争制造者、猪猡、军工复合体等形成一种非常鲜明的对比。因此，人们把鲜花插在枪管里的经典形象，非常具有霍夫曼-鲁宾式的风格。这些人曾在1967年10月联合参与了向五角大楼进军的行动，并在华盛顿特区中心领导了这场规模巨大的抗议活动。他们向五角大楼游行，高唱歌曲，试图驱魔并让五角大楼悬浮起来。现在很显然
a lot of people read about this in the newspapers or saw it on TV and thought these people are demented. The Pentagon cannot by definition be levitated, but it's all part of their thing, which is about silliness. You know, don't engage with the military industrial complex on its own terms or the establishment politics, but challenge it through radical theater, singing, chanting, make them look stupid. Yes. So these guys were smoking dope one day at Hoffman's apartment in the East Village.
许多人在报纸上读到或在电视上看到这一幕，认为这些人疯了。五角大楼根据定义是不可能悬浮起来的，但这都是他们那一套荒诞行为的一部分。你知道的，不要在军工复合体自己的地盘上与它交锋，也不要用建制派政治与之对抗，而是要通过激进的戏剧、歌唱、吟诵来挑战它，让他们看起来像傻瓜。是的。所以这些家伙有一天在霍夫曼位于东村的公寓里抽大麻。
And Dominic, they loved dope. There's an awful lot of it. Yeah. Hoffman was high all the way through his wedding. Spent the whole time giggling. Well, I think he was high through a large proportion of his life, frankly. So they're sitting with their mates in the East Village in New York City, and they come up with the idea of basically staging a fun youth festival at the
多米尼克，他们太爱大麻了。里面有大量的这种东西。是的。霍夫曼在他的整个婚礼期间都处于嗨的状态。整个过程都在傻笑。好吧坦白说，我觉得他一生中有很大一部分时间都处于嗨的状态。所以他们和同伴们坐在纽约市的东村，想出了一个主意，基本上是在民主党大会期间
democratic convention to show up the Democratic delegates. The politics are fun. And their friend, Paul Krasner, who's sitting around with them on bean bags or whatever they're doing, says, why don't we call it YIPPEE? We'll be the YIPPEES. And then Hoffman's wife Anita said we should think up a different name. So for the straights, we'll say that the YIPP stands for the Y-I-P, the Youth International Party. And the media will take that seriously, but the kids will know that this is all just a joke and that very... Yeah, it's a smoke-in. Exactly. So for the next few months, the early months of 1968, they are producing badges and posters and all with
举办一个有趣的青年节，来让民主党代表们难堪。政治很有趣。和他们一起坐在懒人沙发上或者无论他们在干什么的他们的朋友保罗·克拉斯纳说，我们为什么不叫它 YIPPEE（耶皮）呢？我们就是 YIPPEES（耶皮士）。然后霍夫曼的妻子安妮塔说，我们应该想一个不同的名字。所以对于正统派，我们会说 YIPP 代表 Y-I-P，即青年国际党（Youth International Party）。媒体会认真对待这一点，但孩子们会知道这其实只是一个玩笑，而且非常……是的，这是一场抽大麻的集会。没错。所以在接下来的几个月里，也就是1968年的头几个月，他们一直在制作徽章和海报，全都是
psychedelic logos. They've got a marijuana leaf, haven't they, on a kind of purple background, I think. Yeah, it's all pink and purple. Exactly. Exactly. They want to get the LSD guru, Timothy Leary. They want to get the beat poet, Alan Ginsburg. They want to get kind of folk singers like Phil Oakes. They want to get these kind of slightly counter-cultural people to join him. Now there is a tension in the Yippee vision because Hoffman is all about having fun. And he says, you know, what we're going to do is we will basically have the model of the alternative society on the Democrats' doorstep.
迷幻风格的标志。我想他们在一个类似于紫色背景的上面印有大麻叶，对吧？是的，全都是粉红色和紫色的。没错。没错。他们想把 LSD 导师蒂莫西·Leary 请来。他们想把垮掉派诗人艾伦·金斯堡请来。他们想把菲尔·奥克斯这样的民谣歌手请来。他们想让这些略带反主流文化色彩的人加入进来。现在嬉皮士的愿景中存在着一种紧张关系，因为霍夫曼一心只想获得快乐。他说（你知道的），我们要做的基本上是在民主党人的家门口建立一个另类社会的模型。
We'll be all reading poetry and making love and stuff. They'll feel terrible because they'll realize their lives are worthless. Rubin is much more confrontational and he told a meeting in New York, he said basically we're gonna bring half a million people to Chicago, we'll camp out, we'll smoke pot, we'll dance, we'll burn our draft cards and I quote, raw like wild bands through the streets, forcing the president to bring troops home from Vietnam to keep order in the city while he is nominated under the protection of tear gas and bayonets. Does he wants to provoke mass violence?
我们会一起读诗、做爱之类的。他们会感到糟糕透顶，因为他们会意识到自己的生活毫无价值。鲁宾则更具对抗性，他在纽约的一次会议上说，基本上我们要带五十万人去芝加哥，我们要在那里露营、抽大麻、跳舞、烧掉我们的征兵卡，我引用他的话说：“像野兽一样在街头咆哮，迫使总统把军队从越南撤回来在城里维持秩序，而他则在催泪瓦斯和刺刀的保护下被提名。”他是想挑起大规模暴力吗？
He does. He's asked about this and he says, a movement cannot grow without repression. And some people are like, really? Do we want all the bayonets and stuff? So Alan Ginsberg, the poet says, I see bloody visions of the apocalypse. The trouble is he always says that. So he loves Blake, doesn't he? He's always quoting Blake.
他确实是。当被问及此事时，他说：“没有镇压，运动就无法成长。”有些人就觉得：真的吗？我们想要所有的刺刀之类的东西吗？所以诗人艾伦·金斯堡说：“我看到了末日的血腥幻象。”问题是他总是这么说。所以他热爱布莱克，不是吗？他总是引用布莱克的话。
So people don't listen. However, I think right from the start, there is a slight sense that if you keep talking about all this, if you say you're going to go roaring through the streets, it's unrealistic to expect the authorities not to take you seriously and to make the appropriate preparations, which is of course what happens. And especially when you've got a mayor of the city who'd love to have a crack at a yippie. Exactly, exactly. So their project runs into trouble really when Johnson pulls out because they needed the big baddie. Yeah, they've lost their enemy.
所以人们不听。然而，我认为从一开始就有一种微妙的感觉：如果你一直谈论这一切，如果你说你要在街头咆哮，指望当局不严肃对待你并做出适当的准备是不切实际的，而这当然也是后来发生的事情。尤其是当你有一个渴望好好教训一下嬉皮士的市长时。没错，确实如此。所以当约翰逊退选时，他们的计划遇到了麻烦，因为他们需要那个大反派。是的，他们失去了敌人。
They've lost their enemy. Then it all goes quiet. Maybe it's not going to happen. Then Robert Kennedy is shot. They say, oh, well, that proves we were right. Rubin said rather tastelessly, Sahan Sahan is a yippie. And they said, brilliant, we're back on. So they resuscitate their plan, all the poetry and all this stuff, and they're going to have this big march to confront the Democrats. The big problem they have is they need permits. To stage a
他们失去了敌人。然后一切都安静了。也许这不会发生了。接着罗伯特·肯尼迪被枪击了。他们说，哦，好吧，这证明了我们是对的。鲁宾相当轻率地说：“萨罕、萨罕是个嬉皮士。”他们说，太棒了，我们又回来了。于是他们恢复了他们的计划，所有的诗歌和所有这些东西，他们将举行一场声势浩大的游行来对抗民主党。他们面临的最大问题是他们需要许可证。要举办
big demonstration, you need a degree of cooperation. You have to be allowed to sleep in the park. You have to be allowed to put up your stage. You know, all of these kind of mundane things. And they are trying to do that, but it's very clear to them that the city of Chicago has no interest whatsoever in cooperating, that dailies people keep putting off the meetings or putting off a decision. But also, I mean, certificates and stuff, I mean, they're a bit square, aren't they? They are square, but there are people in this movement in the underground who know that you do need the permits, right? So the people actually in Chicago, Yippies in Chicago, become quite worried about this. At the beginning of August,
一场盛大的游行，你需要一定程度的合作。你必须被允许在公园里睡觉。你必须被允许搭建你的舞台。你知道的，所有这些世俗的事情。他们正在努力做到这一点，但对他们来说很明显，芝加哥市对合作完全没有兴趣，戴利的手下一直在推迟会议或推迟做出决定。而且，许可证之类的东西，我的意思是，它们有点太循规蹈矩了吧？它们是循规蹈矩的，但这个运动中、地下组织中有人知道你确实需要许可证，对吧？所以实际上在芝加哥的人，芝加哥的嬉皮士开始对此感到非常担忧。八月初，
one of the leading lights of the kind of Chicago counterculture, who's a journalist called APEC, sent out a public letter called A Letter From Chicago. And he says, guys, the organization for this is a complete shambles. It's going to be really heavy. It's going to be very heavy. The authorities have been freaked out by the talk of violence. And he says, you know, I love a protest as much as anybody, but I quote, it is a black piece of action. It involves masquerading as the pied piper of peace. And he says, I'm just saying if
芝加哥反主流文化的中坚力量之一、一位名叫 APEC 的记者发表了一封题为《来自芝加哥的信》的公开信。他说，伙计们，这里的组织工作简直一团糟。这将会非常沉重。这会非常沉重。当局已经被暴力言论吓坏了。他说（你知道的），我像任何人一样热爱抗议，但我引用他的话：“这是一个黑暗的行动。它涉及冒充和平的吹笛手。”他说：“我只是想说，如果你
you're going to come to Chicago, be sure to wear some armour in your hair. Very good. Now the thing is nobody listens to him and they should have done because Hoffman and Rubin the New Yorkers, say, these Chicago people are absolute wimps and weeds. What do you expect from these provincial hicks? You know, we know better. So there's a bit of a rift between the Chicago people and the New York people.
要来芝加哥，确保你的头发里戴了某种盔甲。”非常好。问题是没人听他的话，而他们本该听的。因为纽约来的霍夫曼和鲁宾说，这些芝加哥人简直是懦夫和胆小鬼。你还能指望这些地方土包子什么呢？你知道的，我们更懂。所以芝加哥人和纽约人之间产生了一些裂痕。
The New York people then do something, I think, very foolish. They are hoping to mobilize the African-American population of Chicago. And their strategy for doing this is to try to make contact with the largest gang in the city, the Blackstone Rangers. Now they don't obviously have any joy. The Blackstone Rangers have no interest in having reading poems.
纽约人随后做了一件我认为非常愚蠢的事。他们希望动员芝加哥的非裔美国人。他们实现这一目标的策略是试图与该市最大的帮派“布莱克斯通游骑兵”（Blackstone Rangers）建立联系。现在他们显然没有取得任何进展。布莱克斯通游骑兵对听读诗歌毫无兴趣。
However, as we will see, word of this reaches the Chicago police and it completely freaks them out because obviously they say, what's going on? These hippies are in alliance with these bad guys from the streets. Anyway, the convention approaches August 1968. The Chicago underground are now very concerned about what's going to happen and they issue another statement begging people not to come. The word is out. The cops will riot.
然而，正如我们将会看到的，这个消息传到了芝加哥警察的耳朵里，把他们吓坏了，因为显然他们在说：这到底是怎么回事？这些嬉皮士竟然和这些街头恶棍勾结在一起。无论如何，代表大会临近了，1968年8月。芝加哥地下组织现在非常担心将要发生的事情，他们发表了另一份声明，恳求人们不要来。消息已经传出去了。警察会暴动。
Chicago may host a festival of blood. But Hoffman, he's not put off, is he? Not at all. He's saying he wants five days of energy exchange, which is kind of what he's going to get. Well, the New York people are all there by about the 20th of August. Which I think, isn't that also the date that the Soviet Union invades Czechoslovakia, which is kind of grumbling away in the background to all this. And so that provides more scope for them to compare Chicago to Prague.
芝加哥可能会迎来一场血腥的节日。但霍夫曼并没有被吓退，不是吗？一点也没有。他说他想要五天的能量交流，这基本上就是他将要得到的。好吧，纽约人大约在8月20日左右就全都在那里了。我想，那不也是苏联入侵捷克斯洛伐克的日子吗？这件事在这一切的背景下隐隐作响。所以这为他们把芝加哥与布拉格进行比较提供了更多空间。
There's definitely an element of role playing in this, right? The Chicago convention is unfolding at exactly the same point as the Prague Spring. And so a lot of people are saying, oh, these are two sides of the same coin. People are confronting the war makers on both sides of the Iron Curtain. Soviet tanks, Chicago pigs. Exactly right. On the 22nd of August, Hoffman holds a press conference in Chicago and he says, here are our demands, the Yippies demands.
这绝对有一种角色扮演的成分，对吧？芝加哥代表大会展开的时间点与布拉格之春完全吻合。所以很多人都在说，哦，这是同一枚硬币的两面。人们在铁幕的两侧对抗战争制造者。苏联坦克，芝加哥猪猡。完全正确。8月22日，霍夫曼在芝加哥举行了一场新闻发布会，他说：以下是我们的要求，嬉皮士的要求。
They are not unpredictably legalize marijuana. That's a full employment. Turn all the mass media over to the people. End imperialism. Abolish money. Make love, not war. And the last one is blank. He says so people can fill in whatever they want. And the manifesto ends. Political pigs, your days are numbered. We are the second American revolution. We shall win. Yippee. It's not yippee. I suppose it's ambivalent, isn't it? You're thinking yippee in the sort of a slide at a children's party, are you?
它们并不出人意料地包括：合法化大麻。实现充分就业。把所有大众传媒交还给人民。结束帝国主义。废除金钱。做爱，不要作战。最后一个是空白的。他说这样人们就可以填入他们想要的任何东西。宣言结束时的口号是：政治猪猡，你们的日子不多了。我们是第二次美国革命。我们必胜。耶皮。这不是耶皮。我想这是模棱两可的，不是吗？你以为的“耶皮”是在儿童派对上滑一下的那种吗？
Yippee. See, I think of it as more slightly downbeat, yeah, like a bit more stoned, I guess. I don't know. Now the mainstream people, the mob, are very anxious about the hippies being there. They see them as irresponsible and narcissistic. But the mob also are conscious of the potential for violence. So violence, you could say, is built into their protest model too.
耶皮。你看，我觉得它更稍微低落一点，对吧，有点像更嗑大了的那种，我猜。我不知道。现在主流人群，Moab，对嬉皮士的存在感到非常焦虑。他们认为这些人不负责任且自恋。但 Moab 也意识到暴力的潜在可能。所以暴力，可以说是内置于他们的抗议模式中的。
Their slogan, confront the war makers, you know, has the kind of implicit suggestion that stuff might kick off. And their poster is a kind of very aggressive poster. It shows a pig, literally a pig, holding a club, wearing a police helmet, sort of dancing or stamping on a map of Chicago. And I guess that brings us to the other great actors in this drama, which is the Chicago police. You might have the sort of stereotypical vision of the Chicago police.
他们的口号“对抗战争制造者”，你知道的，带有某种暗示事情可能会爆发的含意。他们的海报是一种极具侵略性的海报。它展示了一头猪，字面意义上的一头猪，手里拿着警棍，戴着警帽，在芝加哥地图上跳舞或踩踏。我想这把我们带到了这场戏剧中的另一个伟大演员，也就是芝加哥警察。你可能对芝加哥警察有一种刻板印象。
So they're just enormous burly men eating donuts. Yeah. Who never smile and love cracking heads. And actually that would be a little bit harsh. There's a really good book on this by a guy called David Farber. And I can remember he published it, I think in the late eighties or early nineties. I read many accounts of this convention, but I've never read one in which it had ever occurred to the author to give the story from the point of view of the Chicagoans, of the Chicago
所以他们只是吃着甜甜圈的魁梧壮汉。是的。从不微笑并且热爱爆头。实际上这可能有点过于严苛了。一个叫大卫·法伯的人写了一本关于这方面的非常棒的书。我记得他是...我想是在八十年代末或九十年代初出版的。我读过很多关于这次代表大会的记述，但我从未读过哪一本让作者萌生出从芝加哥人、芝加哥警察的角度来讲述这个故事的想法。
police. So he points out, the Chicago police are not enormously backward. They had been modernized in the previous 10 years by the most innovative police superintendent in the country, it was a guy called O.W. Wilson, and he had promoted and aggressively recruited black officers. So actually, one in four of the Chicago police are black, a better proportion than most other American cities. Yeah, that's not part of the image you have of the events, is it? Never part of the image, but it's important to have that in mind.
所以他指出，芝加哥警察并不是极其落后的。他们在过去10年中被全国最具创新精神的警察局长实现了现代化，那个人叫 O·W·威尔逊，他提拔并大力招募黑人警官。所以实际上，芝加哥警察中四分之一是黑人，这个比例比大多数其他美国城市都要好。是的，这并不是你对这些事件印象的一部分，对吗？从来都不是印象的一部分，但把这一点记在心里很重要。
The morale of the Chicago police is rock bottom. Crime had been growing five times faster than population had, and the threats to policemen's health, life, and so on, are greater than ever before. However, they feel, if you ask a cop, they feel unsupported by the courts, by the political system, and indeed by the public. They feel that their hands tied the courts, by the political system, and indeed by the public. They feel that their hands tied behind their back, all of this kind of thing. I'm not saying I necessarily agree with them. But that's their take.
芝加哥警察的士气降到了谷底。犯罪率的增长速度是人口增长速度的五倍，而对警察健康、生命等的威胁比以往任何时候都要大。然而，他们觉得，如果你问一个警察，他们觉得法庭、政治体制乃至公众都不支持他们。他们觉得自己被法庭、政治体制乃至公众绑住了手脚，所有这些。我并不是说我一定同意他们的看法。但这就是他们的态度。
That's their take. They're conscious, their pay has fallen behind. Farber points out they're paid less than plumbers, less than glaziers, and a lot of other what he calls low status workers. So they're not the elite of the working class by any means. And they feel what they hate more than anything, and I quote, ill-mannered self-righteous college kids whom they believed came from privileged backgrounds protesting in the streets and mixing with and supporting Negroes about whom they knew nothing.
这就是他们的看法。他们意识到，他们的薪水已经落后了。法伯指出，他们的薪酬比水管工低，比玻璃工低，比他所说的许多其他低地位工人还要低。所以他们绝不是工人阶级的精英。他们感到最痛恨、我引述他的话说，是“那些行为粗鲁、自以为是的大学生，他们认为这些人来自特权阶层，在街头抗议，并与他们一无所知的黑人混在一起并支持他们”。
They resented the middle-class demonstrators who talked about equality and freedom, but showed no respect for authority or understanding of those who just wanted to keep the simple things they had worked for so hard. So that is their mindset. Okay. There is class-based tension. Definitely there's class-based tension. Right from the beginning. Huge amounts of class tension. Also, the Chicago police have come in for severe criticism in 68, not for being too harsh,
他们痛恨那些谈论平等和自由却对权威毫无尊重、也不理解那些只想守住自己辛苦换来的简单东西的人的中产阶级示威者。所以这就是他们的心态。好的。这里存在基于阶级的紧张关系。绝对存在基于阶级的紧张关系。从一开始就有。大量的阶级紧张。此外，芝加哥警察在68年受到了严厉批评，不是因为他们太严厉，
but for being too weak. So after Martin Luther King's assassination in April, there had been days of rioting in Chicago. 11 people had been killed and 500 injured and there'd been thousands of arrests. Now the civil rights leaders in the city laid into the police and said, you know, shouldn't have gone in so hard, all of this. Mayor Daley came out and said, I was disappointed the police were so weak. He said, we should be a city of order. Their police chiefs should have told their men that with arsonists, he's horrified by the arson.
而是因为他们太软弱。所以在马丁·路德·金于4月被暗杀后，芝加哥发生了数天的骚乱。11人死亡，500人受伤，数千人被捕。现在该市的民权领袖痛斥警察，说（你知道的）本不该下手这么重，诸如此类。戴利市长出来说：“我对警察如此软弱感到失望。”他说：“我们应该是一个秩序井然的城市。他们的警察局长本该告诉手下，面对纵火犯……”他被纵火吓坏了。
chiefs should have told their men that with arsonists, he's horrified by the arson. And he says arsonists, we should shoot to kill. When people are looting, we shoot to maim. That was his expression. And so with that robust approach to law and order, what is Daly's response to the yippies turning up and Hoffman suggesting that they're planning to put LSD into the Chicago city water supply. Well, you see, this is the thing. Does this go down well? It doesn't go down well at all. Because remember, the Yippies are saying all this publicly. They're not just saying it among themselves. They are saying, for example, we will block all the
局长本该告诉手下，对于纵火犯，他厌恶纵火，并且他说对于纵火犯，我们应该格杀勿论。当人们打砸抢烧时，我们格杀勿论。这是他的原话。因此，在采取这种强硬的法律和秩序方针时，戴利对嬉皮士的出现以及霍夫曼建议他们计划把LSD投入芝加哥城市供水系统的反应是什么？好吧，你看，这就是问题所在。这行得通吗？一点也行得通。因为记住，嬉皮士们是公开这么说的。他们不只是私下说说。例如，他们说，我们会封锁所有的
expressways. We will, as you said, Tom, I mean, this is the story that's repeated in every newspaper, dose the water supply with LSD. We will storm the amphitheatre. We will invade the hotels. And they wanted to paint cars to look like taxis. All of this stuff. And kidnap delegates and dump them. But I mean, you'd have to be a square who's not familiar with Antoine Auteau to take it
高速公路。我们将会，正如你所说，汤姆，我的意思是，这是每家报纸都在报道的故事，把LSD投入供水系统。我们要冲进露天剧场。我们要侵入酒店。他们还想把汽车漆成出租车的样子。所有这些东西。还要绑架代表并把他们扔掉。但是我的意思是，你得是一个不熟悉安托万·奥托（Antoine Auteau）的老土才会把这当真，对吧？我的意思是，只有老土才会这么做。
literally, right? I mean, only a square would do that. I think in a country which has seen years of urban rioting and also has seen a president shot dead five years earlier, the leading civil rights leader, one of the most famous men in the world shot dead that April and a presidential candidate shot dead in June. It is implausible to imagine the city authorities not taking these threats seriously. But Dominic, they are not real threats, are they? I mean, they are ludic threats.
我认为在一个经历过多年城市骚乱的国家里，五年前还看到过一位总统被枪杀，民权运动领袖、世界上最著名的人物之一在那个四月被枪杀，还有一位总统候选人在六月被枪杀。很难想象城市当局不会认真对待这些威胁。但是多米尼克，这些并不是真正的威胁，不是吗？我的意思是，它们是荒诞的威胁。
They are street theatre. They are... I suppose so. I mean, if your car is painted to look like a taxi, you'd probably find it enormously annoying, wouldn't you? Yeah, they're not really planning to do it. They're not really planning to do any of this stuff. I think they are planning to do some of it, actually.
它们是街头戏剧。它们是……我想是吧。我的意思是，如果你的车被漆成出租车的样子，你可能会觉得极其烦人，不是吗？是的，他们并不是真的打算这么做。他们并不是真的打算做所有这些事情。其实我觉得他们确实打算做其中的一部分。
They're planning to do stunts. Because they talk think they are planning to do some of it actually. They're planning to do stunts. Because they talk about setting up mortars and aiming it at the Democrat. Yeah, they're not going to do that. I mean, it's obviously exaggerated. But it's easy for you and me, right? Of course. All these years after the event to sit back and say, well, they are going to do this,
他们打算搞噱头。因为他们谈论……其实我觉得他们打算做其中的一部分。他们打算搞噱头。因为他们谈论设立迫击炮并将其瞄准民主党人。是的，他们不会那样做。我的意思是，这显然是夸张的。但对你我来说很容易，对吧？当然。事发多年后，我们可以坐在这里说，嗯，他们要做这个，
they're not going to do that. How can Daley and his police? But it's another manifestation of this class based tension. Because if you're kind of hip, you've been to an arts college, you've studied theatre, you know that this is obviously a joke. But if you're, as you say, a harassed police chief, of course you're not going to think it's a joke. Of course. So as August approaches, the Yippee supporters are kind of tooling up with flowers
他们不做那个。戴利和他的警察怎么能……但这又是这种基于阶级的紧张关系的一种表现。因为如果你有点时髦，你上过艺术学院，你学过戏剧，你知道这显然是个笑话。但如果你像你所说的那样，是一个饱受折磨的警察局长，你当然不会认为这是个笑话。当然。因此随着八月的临近，嬉皮士的支持者们开始带着鲜花
and books of poetry and jostics or whatever. But Daly's police, they are all issued with riot helmets, they're all given personal tear gas sprays, they're given a shotgun in every car. Frunchans, all the stuff. They are actually expecting an armed rebellion. One of Daly's officials says, we are looking forward to the battle of the century. Oh goodness, I think we should take a break there and when we come back we'll find out if he's right, if we really are facing the battle of the century.
和诗集以及香棒之类的东西做好准备。但是戴利的警察，他们都配备了防暴头盔，都发了个人催泪瓦斯喷雾，每辆车里都配了一把猎枪。警棍，所有这些东西。他们实际上在期待一场武装叛乱。戴利的一位官员说，我们正期待着世纪之战。哦天哪，我想我们应该在那里休息一下，当我们回来时，我们会发现他是对的，我们是否真的面临世纪之战。
A great stillness rose up from the street through all the small noise of clubbing and cries, small sirens. Sigh of loaded arrest vans as off they pulled, shouts of police as they wheeled in larger circles. The intersection clearing further, then further, a stillness rose through the steel and stone of the hotel, congregating in the shocked centers of every room where delegates and their wives and press and campaign workers, innocent until now of the intimate working of social force, look down now into the murderous paradigm of Vietnam there beneath them at this huge intersection of this great city.
一股极大的寂静从街道升起，穿过所有挥舞棍棒的微小噪音、哭喊声和小小的警笛声。满载着被捕者的防暴车发出叹息声，随着它们驶离，警察在迂回盘旋时发出叫喊声。十字路口进一步空旷，然后进一步空旷，寂静穿过酒店的钢铁和石头，聚集在每个房间震惊的中心，代表和他们的妻子、媒体以及竞选工作人员，在此之前对社会力量的亲密运作一无所知，现在向下俯视，看着他们下方那越南的谋杀性范例，在这座伟大城市的这个巨大十字路口。
That was Norman Mailer in Miami and the siege of Chicago. And he's writing about the climax of this battle of the century that one of Daly's officials had promised taking place in the streets of Chicago. So Dominic, before we get to that climax, how does it all play out? How does it begin? So to give people a sense of the geography, the downtown area of Chicago is called The Loop and the main hotels and office blocks are along Michigan Avenue, which runs north to south. So you've got that.
那是诺曼·梅勒在迈阿密和芝加哥围城战中的言论。他写的是戴利的一位官员承诺在芝加哥街头发生的世纪之战的高潮。所以多米尼克，在我们到达那个高潮之前，这一切是如何展开的？它是如何开始的？所以为了让人们对地理有一个概念，芝加哥的市中心被称为环形区（The Loop），主要的酒店和办公大楼都在密歇根大道沿线，这条大道从北向南延伸。所以你有了这个。
Adjoining The Loop next to Lake Michigan is Grant Park. Now further to the north, you have another park, which is called Lincoln Park. And then to the south, there are the great stockyards on which Chicago was built, the biggest in the world. So Norman Mailer in his book, he starts the section about Chicago with a brilliant, brilliant sort of portrait of these stockyards of the blood and the work and all this. And this is quite a distance from the centre, right? From the downtown. Yes. About six miles or something.
紧邻密歇根湖畔环形区的是格兰特公园。再往北，你还有另一个公园，叫做林肯公园。然后向南，是芝加哥建立所在的巨大牲畜屠宰场，是世界上最大的。所以诺曼·梅勒在他的书里，他以一篇精彩绝伦的肖像画般的文章开始了关于芝加哥的部分，描绘了这些牲畜屠宰场的鲜血、工作和所有这一切。这离中心有一段距离，对吧？离市中心。是的。大约六英里左右。
And next to the stockyards is the amphitheatre where the convention will take place. The hotels are in the centre, but the amphitheatre is to the south and the amphitheatre is ringed by a huge barbed wire fence. There are roadblocks, there are armed police, thousands of them on patrol. There's a no fly zone above. There is maximum security. So the Yippies have set up shop in Lincoln Park quite a long way away. And on the Friday before the convention week, they are handing
在屠宰场旁边是举行代表大会的露天剧场。酒店在中心，但露天剧场在南面，露天剧场周围环绕着巨大的铁丝网栅栏。有路障，有武装警察，成千上万的人在巡逻。上面有禁飞区。有最高级别的安全戒备。所以嬉皮士们在离得很远的林肯公园开店了。在代表大会周开始前的星期五，他们正在向人们分发
out maps and flyers to people. There are only a few hundred of them, nowhere near the thousands they had hoped for. I have to say, Tom, their flyers do not suggest a terribly progressive attitude towards gender relations. Chicks who can type and spell, cats who have wheels and want to do a digger trip to feed the masses. Yeah. If you are a chick who can type, I think you might feel a little bit triggered, I believe is the word by that time. Or indeed, if you're a chick at all, whether you can type or not.
地图和传单。他们只有几百人，远没有他们希望的数千人那样多。我必须说，汤姆，他们的传单并不表明他们对性别关系有着非常进步的态度。会打字和拼写的辣妹，有车想去搞一趟“挖掘者”之旅来喂饱大众的猫们。是的。如果你是一个会打字的辣妹，我想你可能会觉得有点被触动，我想那是那个时候的用词。或者实际上，如果你根本就是个辣妹，不管你会不会打字。
So they are handing out maps of the democratic hotels and saying, written on them, break in, break in, break in, security precautions taken by the convention bigwigs are a farce. Again, they think this is very funny. If you're a police agent or something, you read this with a sense of kind of horror. Oh my God, they're going to break into the hotels, right? And so do you find it funny that they're also staging their own nomination battle to elect a president and this president is going to be called Pigasus and he's a pig. And Hoffman, he's brought along a pretty pig, an attractive pig, a sweet little pig.
所以他们分发民主党酒店的地图，上面写着：闯进去，闯进去，闯进去，大会大人物们采取的安全防范措施全都是个笑话。同样，他们认为这非常有趣。如果你是一个警察特工什么的，你读到这个时会有一种恐惧感。哦天哪，他们要闯入酒店了，对吧？那么你觉得有趣的是，他们还在上演他们自己的提名战来选出一个总统，而这个总统将被称为“皮加苏斯”（Pigasus），他是一头猪。而霍夫曼，他带来了一头漂亮的猪，一头有吸引力的猪，一只可爱的小猪。
And Rubin has brought along an ugly pig and Rubin's ugly pig gets the nomination. And he then gives a big kind of nomination speech for pick us, doesn't he? Yes. He gets arrested and charged with disturbing the police, but he then gets released. And then the next day they've got another pig. So there's more pig based Yippee humor. And they set him loose in Lincoln park.
而鲁宾带来了一头丑陋的猪，鲁宾丑陋的猪获得了提名。然后他发表了一篇针对“皮加苏斯”的大型提名演讲，不是吗？是的。他被捕并被控扰乱警察，但他随后被释放了。然后第二天他们又弄来了一头猪。所以有更多基于猪的嬉皮士幽默。他们把它放生在林肯公园里。
And this apparently is the female pig. And this is going to be the candidate's wife. So it's going to be what the first pig lady and the police are kind of rushing around trying to catch this pig and the yippies are all shouting pig pig because you know, is it a pig or is it the police? It's all very funny. Yeah. And then when the police finally get the pig, they all shout out, be careful with the next first lady. Do you find that funny? I don't perhaps find it as funny as some people do to be brutally honest. I think it's quite funny. So in the break, Theo complained and said, you're being very kind to the police, explaining their worldview and you're not being kind enough to the yippies. I feel that this isn't
这显然是那头母猪。这将是候选人的妻子。所以这将是什么第一夫人猪，警察到处跑着想要抓住这头猪，而嬉皮士们都在大喊“猪，猪”，因为你知道，这是一头猪还是警察？这一切都非常有趣。是的。然后当警察最终抓住这头猪时，他们都大喊，对下一任第一夫人客气点。你觉得这有趣吗？说实话，我可能觉得它没有某些人想象的那么有趣。我觉得这挺有趣的。所以在休息时，西奥抱怨说，你对警察太好了，解释他们的世界观，而你对嬉皮士不够好。我觉得这
tremendous behavior from the yippies, to be honest, the last couple of moments we've had from them. I feel they've let themselves down a little bit with the pig and with the chicks. I think all that. I think more with the chicks than with the pigs. Well, animal rights people will pronounce on that, Tom. You'd rather be nominated for president than be kind of chopped up and slaughtered in the stockyard. In the stockyard, wouldn't you?
不是嬉皮士的极好行为，说实话，这是他们最近表现出来的几个时刻。我觉得他们在猪和辣妹的问题上让自己有点失望了。我想这一切。我觉得在辣妹的问题上比在猪的问题上更多。嗯，动物权利人士会对这一点发表意见的，汤姆。你宁愿被提名竞选总统，也不愿在屠宰场里被切碎和屠宰，在屠宰场里，对吧？
Maybe. Well, I suspect that a lot of those pigs had both those experiences, to be fair. Yeah, I guess. All right. So the Saturday night, the 24th of August, there's the first little confrontation with the police, really. Police wanted the hippies to clear out of Lincoln Park by 11 o'clock, but they basically hate doing that, being told to clear out. Of course, they don't have a permit to sleep in the park, which is a big problem. And this confrontation is diffused by Alan Ginsburg, who sits down and chants, Om. Om. Om. for 20 minutes. And this works.
也许吧。嗯，我怀疑很多那些猪都有这两种经历，公平地说。是的，我想是的。好吧。所以星期六晚上，8月24日，与警察发生了第一次小规模的对峙，真的。警察希望嬉皮士在11点前离开林肯公园，但他们基本上讨厌这样做，被告知离开。当然，他们没有在公园睡觉的许可证，这是一个大问题。这场对峙被艾伦·金斯堡化解了，他坐下来高唱“唵”。唵。唵。持续了20分钟。这起作用了。
He calms the crowd down and he leads them, like on a Pied Piper figure, out of the park. But on the Sunday, it's a different story. So the Sunday the 25th of August, the convention is going to meet the next day. First of all, the sort of mainstream peace movement, the MOBE, they organized a march into the downtown area to the Hilton Hotel, the Hilton where a lot of this action is going to take place. It's right in the center of Chicago on Michigan Avenue. All the big wigs are staying there and the campaigns have their headquarters there and they are down below the hotel, some of them waving Viet Cong flags and chanting, hey, hey, LBJ, how many kids did you kill today? That traditional kind of chant. But the real confrontation comes back in Lincoln Park to the North.
他让愤怒的人群平静下来，并像个吹笛手一样，把他们领出了公园。但到了星期天，情况就不同了。所以在8月25日星期天，大会将于第二天召开。首先，主流和平运动“MOBE”组织了一场游行，进入市中心前往希尔顿酒店，许多行动都将在希尔顿酒店发生。它位于芝加哥市中心的密歇根大道上。所有的大人物都住在那里，各个竞选阵营也将总部设在那里，他们就在酒店下方，其中一些人挥舞着越共旗帜并高呼：“嘿，嘿，LBJ，你今天杀了几百小孩？”那种传统的口号。但真正的对峙回到了北部的林肯公园。
This is where the Yippies were going to have their festival of life. And there were all these bands going to come and it was going to be brilliant. And actually it's like one of those festivals that people organize these days for Instagramers in the Caribbean or something, where they all end up stranded on a desert island with no food. Or like those Christmas festivals that turn out to be a sheep with an antler on it. That's right, exactly. So only one band turns up, it's a local band called the MC5. They expected a hundred thousand people to come, they get about three or four thousand. There's a big dispute with the police about electricity and if they can use a stage. There's a big dispute with the police about electricity and if they can use a stage. And there's a lot of tension between the crowd and the police, a lot of shouting obscenities
这就是嬉皮士们要举办他们“生活节”的地方。有那么多乐队要来，这本该是精彩绝伦的。实际上，这就好像人们现在为加勒比海的Instagram网红们组织的那些节日一样，大家最后都搁浅在一个没有食物的荒岛上。或者就像那些最终变成一只头上长着鹿角的绵羊的圣诞节节日。没错，完全如此。所以只有一个乐队出现，是一个叫MC5的当地乐队。他们期待着十万人来，结果只来了三四千人。他们和警察就电力以及是否能使用舞台发生了巨大的争端。他们和警察就电力以及是否能使用舞台发生了巨大的争端。人群和警察之间有很多紧张气氛，许多人大喊粗口，
and the police kind of cracking heads and stuff. And as darkness falls, there is a very tense atmosphere. There's a change over in the police shift. So a new load of police arrive and they are told by their departing comrades, it's all going to kick off this evening. You know, you've got to be ready to crack some heads. and they are told by their departing comrades, it's all going to kick off this evening. You know, you've got to be ready to crack some heads. Allen Ginsberg starts chanting, BOM again.
而警察则在砸碎脑袋之类的。随着夜幕降临，气氛非常紧张。警察换班了。所以新的一批警察到达了，他们的前任同事告诉他们，今晚要出大事了。你知道，你们得准备好打破几个脑袋。他们的前任同事告诉他们，今晚要出大事了。你知道，你们得准备好打破几个脑袋。艾伦·金斯堡开始再次高呼“唵”。
And he does this, I mean, I find this extraordinary. He does it for seven hours. Yeah, he ends up with a very sore throat. Yeah, frankly, I sometimes have a sore throat after a Rest His History Live show, like the ones for which there are still tickets available in New York, Philadelphia and Los Angeles. Because we don't want to look like the yippies, do we? Am I right? Alone in an empty park.
他这样做了，我的意思是，我觉得这太不可思议了。他连续七个小时这样做。是的，他最后嗓子哑得很厉害。是的，坦率地说，有时我在“余生历史”现场演出后也会嗓子哑，就像那些在纽约、费城和洛杉矶仍然有票出售的演出一样。因为我们不想看起来像嬉皮士，对吧？我说的对吗？独自在一个空荡荡的公园里。
Oh, if it's like that, imagine it'd be terrible. I'd be all right with that. I'd just sit there and do an ome. Would you? Yeah. No, no, no. I'd like to be like a presidential candidate doing that pointing thing you do with the crowd.
哦，如果是那样的话，想象一下会很糟糕。我倒觉得无所谓。我只会坐在那里念“唵”。是吗？嗯。不，不，不。我想像个总统候选人那样做那个对着人群指指点点的动作。
Yeah, thumbs up. The thumbs up, exactly. That's what the atmosphere will be like. So at 11 o'clock, we're on the Sunday night here, the police are trying to clear the park. The crowd are chanting, hell no, we won't go. A lot of shouting about pigs. And at about midnight, for the first time really in this story, the police discipline breaks. And they just start clubbing people, beating them to the ground.
是的，竖起大拇指。竖起大拇指，完全正确。气氛就是那个样子的。所以在11点，我们现在在星期天晚上，警察正试图清理公园。人群高呼：“不，绝不，我们不去。”许多人高喊关于猪的口号。大约在午夜，在这个故事中真正可以说是第一次，警察的纪律崩溃了。他们开始殴打人们，将他们击倒在地。
And this continues for some considerable time. And ultimately it descends into total and utter chaos. Is this the point where Hugh Hefner comes out of his mansion and gets hit on the head by a pig? Oh, I didn't know that. With a club. And he's so cross about it that he then pays for the publication of a book on police brutality. I think it is around this time. Surely he's been canceled, has he?
这种情况持续了相当长的一段时间。最终它陷入了完全彻底的混乱。这就是休·海夫纳从他的大宅里出来被猪砸到脑袋的时候吗？哦，我不知道这件事。用一根棍子。他对这件事非常生气，于是出资出版了一本关于警察暴行的书。我想大概就是这个时候。难道他已经被取消了吗？
Well, he's got a big mansion in Chicago. Has he? Okay. I think it's around this time. Surely he's been cancelled, has he? Well, he's got a big mansion in Chicago. Has he? Okay. I think it's around this time. So now things really do kick off in the small hours of Sunday to Monday. The police go berserk. They're attacking reporters, photographers, medical volunteers from the peace movement. They are spraying their mace.
好吧，他在芝加哥有一座大宅子。是吗？好吧。我想大约是在这个时候。他肯定被取消资格了吧，不是吗？好吧，他在芝加哥有一座大宅子。是吗？好吧。我想大约是在这个时候。所以现在，周日到周一的凌晨，事情真的开始爆发了。警察彻底疯狂了。他们在攻击记者、摄影师、和平运动的医疗志愿者。他们在喷射催泪喷雾。
They are hurling kind of tear gas grenades everywhere. Some of them take off their badges at this point. They are spraying their mace, they are hurling kind of tear gas grenades everywhere. Some of them take off their badges at this point, it's the first time they've done this in the story and they're hitting people with clubs. There are helicopters buzzing overhead, there are people shouting, clear the streets, clear the streets. You know, it's total kind of- Gotham City.
他们到处投掷那种催泪瓦斯手榴弹。有些人在这个时候摘下了警徽。他们在喷射催泪喷雾，他们到处投掷催泪瓦斯手榴弹。有些人在这个时候摘下了警徽，这是他们在这个故事中第一次这样做，他们用警棍殴打人们。头顶上有直升机嗡嗡作响，有人在喊，清空街道，清空街道。你知道，这完全有点——哥谭市的感觉。
Very Gotham City. Now, Jerry Rubin is watching this and he says to a friend, this is fantastic, this is fantastic and it's only Sunday night. They might declare martial law in this town. Because that's what he has always wanted. He likes the thought of confrontation. Hoffman doesn't. He wants it to be more playful.
非常哥谭市。现在，杰瑞·鲁宾正在看着这一切，他对一个朋友说，这太棒了，这太棒了，而且这还只是周日晚上。他们可能会在这个镇上宣布戒严。因为那正是他一直想要的。他喜欢对抗的想法。霍夫曼不喜欢。他希望过程更有趣一些。
But Rubin kind of likes the thought of a lot of this. So about a thousand people managed to get out of the park. They kind of run down towards the loop to downtown area and, and they're chanting ho, ho, ho chi min. And they're jumping on cars, they are throwing bottles and stuff like this. There are police waiting for them at one of the bridges and they manage to kind of beat them back. And this dies down at about two o'clock in the morning. This is before the convention has even opened.
但鲁宾有点喜欢这种大量冲突的想法。因此，大约有一千人设法逃出了公园。他们跑到环形区域向市中心进发，他们高呼“胡，胡，胡志明”。他们在汽车上跳来跳去，扔瓶子之类的东西。有一座桥上有警察在等着他们，他们设法把警察击退了。这一切在凌晨两点左右平息了。此时大会甚至还没有开幕。
Right? So a lot of people think that it's basically one night of action. It isn't. It's night after night after night. So the next day the convention opens, daily opens it. He has prepared signs reading, we love LBJ. He still really is hoping to get LBJ nominated as president. His fallback position is if necessary, he'll accept Humphrey, but he
对吧？所以很多人认为这基本上只是一晚上的行动。并不是。这是一晚接一晚又一晚。所以第二天大会开幕了，戴利主持开幕。他准备了写着“我们热爱LBJ”的标语。他仍然非常希望能让LBJ被提名为主席。他的备用方案是，如果必要的话，他会接受汉弗莱，但他
really would like LBJ. And he says to the convention that morning, we will not tolerate, and I quote, people who seek to destroy instead of to build, who would make a mockery of our institutions and values. But actually that very evening there is yet more fighting in Lincoln Park because after the previous night, everybody now is expecting it. So the police now come wearing gas masks, they've got gas and smoke grenades and they don't wait before wading into the crowd this time. Again they tear off their badges and again, there is a sense that all the rules have been
真的希望是LBJ。他在那天早上对大会说，我们绝不容忍，我引述一下，“那些企图破坏而不是建设、那些拿我们的机构和价值观开玩笑的人。”但实际上就在那天晚上，林肯公园里发生了更多的冲突，因为经历了前一晚之后，现在每个人都有所预料了。所以警察现在戴着防毒面具来，他们带着毒气和烟雾弹，这次他们不等冲进人群就开始动手了。他们再次撕掉警徽，再次让人觉得所有的规则都已被
suspended, that they are beating people, especially women. They target women a lot. Why is that? Well, women are less likely to fight back. So they're easier targets. But also perhaps there is a sense of frankly, sexual aggression to it. They will target a girl in a very short skirt. They'll beat her to the ground and they get a sort of kick out of doing it, I guess, groups of policemen.
打破了，他们在殴打人们，尤其是女性。他们经常把女性作为目标。为什么会这样？嗯，女性反抗的可能性较小。所以她们是更容易下手的目标。但也许其中也带有一种坦率的性侵犯意味。他们会把目标对准一个穿着极短裙的女孩。把她打倒在地，我想，这群警察从中能得到一种快感。
And there were lots of stories about smashing people's cameras and all of this kind of thing. And then at the end of that confrontation, there are stories about police having ripped off their badges, going through the streets and they slash the tires and smash the windows of cars with McCarthy for president bumper stickers. In their minds, right? The McCarthy campaign, civil rights, beatniks, peace protesters. Actually, I think this is when they beat up Hugh Hefner. Like in a dressing gown. Give him a crack. Oh, definitely. If the man in a dressing gown looking foppish came out of his nice town
有许多关于砸碎人们的相机以及诸如此类事情的报道。然后在冲突结束时，有报道称警察撕掉了警徽，在街上游荡，割破轮胎，砸碎贴有“麦卡锡竞选总统”车标的汽车窗户。在他们的脑海里，对吧？麦卡锡竞选活动、民权运动、垮掉派、和平抗议者。实际上，我想正是在这个时候，他们把休·海夫纳给揍了。就穿着晨衣。挨了一记。哦，绝对的。如果一个穿着晨衣、看起来很虚荣的男人从他漂亮的城镇
house. With bunny girls. Yeah. Whack him. I mean, you'd be mad not to. So Tuesday, the 27th of August is Lyndon Johnson's birthday. He's celebrating it in Texas, but I think there's a part of him, a considerable part of him that is hoping to get a call from Mayor Daley saying they've come to their senses, they're going to nominate you and of course they're not. Would he have accepted do you think?
房子里走出来。带着兔女郎。是的。狠狠揍他。我的意思是，不这么做才怪呢。所以，8月27日星期二是林登·约翰逊的生日。他在德克萨斯州庆祝生日，但我认为他内心深处有一部分、很大一部分，希望接到戴利市长的电话，说他们已经恢复理智了，打算提名你，当然他们并没有。你觉得他会接受吗？
I think Johnson is an enormous egotist. I think he would have found it hard to resist actually. If they came back crawling to him and said, please Mr. President, will you? Yeah, I think he might well have done. But it's not going to happen because actually what's happening is the convention has degenerated into a massive argument about Vietnam policy between the kind of anti-war delegates of Kennedy and McCarthy and the kind of Humphrey loyalists. And there's also a big argument actually which we won't go into, which is very kind of Labour Party in
我认为约翰逊是一个极度自负的人。我认为他实际上会很难抗拒。如果他们灰溜溜地跑回来对他说，求求你，总统先生，你愿意吗？是的，我想他很可能会答应。但这不会发生，因为实际上正在发生的是，大会已经演变成了一场关于越南政策的巨大争论，对立双方是肯尼迪和麦卡锡的反战代表以及汉弗莱的忠实支持者。而且还有一场很大的争论，我们就不细谈了，这非常类似于1981年左右英国工党的
Britain circa 1981 about the party's internal procedures, which takes an enormous amount of time and effort, but I don't want to drive away all our listeners. So by this point, all the major news organizations have already complained to Daley that their men are being beaten up, their reporters are being beaten up, and that enrages him and it makes him even more determined not to give in and to keep to a hard line in the streets. But what also probably contributes to the hard line is that evening, a new face arrives in Lincoln Park to address the yippies and co.
关于党内程序的争论，这占用了大量的时间和精力，但我不想赶走我们所有的听众。所以到这个时候，所有主要的新闻机构都已经向戴利抱怨说，他们的人正在挨打，他们的记者正在挨打，这激怒了他，并使他更加坚定绝不妥协的决心，要在街头采取强硬路线。但可能促成这种强硬路线的另一个原因是，那天晚上，一个新面孔来到林肯公园向嬉皮士等人发表讲话。
And this is the national chairman of the Black Panthers, a guy called Bobby Seale. So that's the militant black organization. Exactly. And Bobby Seale stands up and he says, if a pig comes up to you and starts swinging a billy club and you check around and you've got your piece, you've got to down that pig in defense of yourself. He says, if you pull out your piece, your gum, and you shoot it well, all I'm going to do is pat you on the back and say, keep shooting.
这就是黑豹党的全国主席，一个叫鲍比·西尔的家伙。所以那是激进的黑人组织。正是如此。鲍比·西尔站起来说，如果一头猪（指警察）走到你面前开始挥舞警棍，你环顾四周发现你身上有家伙，为了自卫，你必须把那头猪干掉。他说，如果你掏出家伙，你的枪，然后开枪，我唯一要做的就是拍拍你的背说，继续开枪。
Now again, some people listen to this would say this is clearly not really meant to be taken seriously. This is exaggerated, sensationalist, it's part of the rhetoric of the late sixties. On the other hand, there are quite a lot of guns in America. And again, an FBI informant or a police agent listening to this will go back and say, there are people there who are telling the crowd to shoot us. So you can see how it contributes to the sort of sense of tension. But actually that evening is not quite so bad.
现在同样，听了这话有些人会说，这显然不是真的要当真。这被夸大了，具有煽动性，这是六年代后期言论的一部分。另一方面，美国有很多枪支。同样，听到这话的FBI线人或警察特工会回去报告说，那里有人在煽动人群向我们开枪。所以你可以看出这如何在某种程度上造成了紧张气氛。但实际上那天晚上并没有那么糟。
The police have now brought out a special tear gas dispensing machine powered by a garbage truck, which basically pours out tear gas in the streets of Chicago. So there's tear gas generally drifting through the streets and actually a lot of people are knackered and bruised after the previous evening. So Tuesday is a bit quieter, but also everybody knows the real climax is coming on the Wednesday. Because that's the day that the Democrats are nominating their candidate for president. Exactly. So let's turn to Wednesday. Nine o'clock that morning, Abbie Hoffman is arrested having breakfast at his hotel. The police have clearly been keeping tabs on him.
警察现在推出了一台由垃圾车驱动的特制催泪瓦斯喷洒机，基本上是在芝加哥街头倾倒催泪瓦斯。所以催泪瓦斯普遍在街道上弥漫，而且实际上很多人在前一晚之后都筋疲力尽、浑身是伤。所以周二稍微安静了一些，但大家都知道真正的最高潮将在周三到来。因为那是民主党人提名总统候选人的日子。没错。所以让我们转向周三。那天早上九点，艾比·霍夫曼在酒店吃早餐时被捕。警察显然一直在监视他。
They arrest and charge him with disorderly conduct because he has an Anglo-Saxon word printed on his forehead. They want to make sure basically that he is off the streets. They see him as one of the masterminds of this conspiracy. However, they don't arrest the mainstream peace movement leaders, the MOBE, and they are going to have a rally in Grant Park, which is directly opposite the loop, which is across Michigan Avenue from the big hotels like the Hilton. So at about three o'clock that afternoon, there are about 15,000 people in Grant Park,
他们逮捕并指控他行为不端，因为他的前额上印着一个盎格鲁-撒克逊词汇。他们基本上是想确保他离开街头。他们视他为这场阴谋的主谋之一。然而，他们并没有逮捕主流和平运动的领袖，即MOBE（动员终止越南战争全国委员会），他们打算在格兰特公园举行集会，该公园正对着环形区，隔着密歇根大道与希尔顿等大酒店相对。因此，当天下午三点左右，格兰特公园里大约有15,000人，
and they are Yippies, MOBE peace campaigners, general kind of pacifists and people of that ilk and McCarthy campaign volunteers. So a real mixed bag. And there are hundreds of police and it really starts to turn ugly when a boy, a teenage boy climbs a flagpole by the bandstand in Grant Park and he lowers the American flag or starts to lower it. And at that, some of the police go mental. They push through the crowd, they grab this boy and they start to beat him up. And then the crowd intervenes
他们是嬉皮士、MOBE和平运动倡导者、一般的和平主义者及同类人士，以及麦卡锡竞选志愿者。所以人员非常杂乱。现场有数百名警察，局势真正开始恶化是在一个男孩、一个十几岁的男孩爬上格兰特公园乐队旁边的一根旗杆，降下美国国旗或开始降旗的时候。见此情景，一些警察发疯了。他们冲进人群，抓住这个男孩开始殴打他。然后人群介入了
and attacks the police and there's a bit of fighting. More teenagers climb the flagpole and they bring down the flag and they hoist a red t-shirt. And at that, the police go berserk. They wade in again. And for the first time now, they explicitly target some of the organizers. So there's a MOBE organizer, a guy called Rennie Davis. They target him, they get him down on the ground. A huge group of them beat him senseless. There's blood everywhere and he has to be rushed to hospital. And at that point, his friend, who's a guy called Tom Hayden, who was one of the most, probably the most best known student leader in America or had
并袭击了警察，双方发生了一些混战。更多的青少年爬上旗杆，拉下国旗，升起了一件红色T恤。见此情景，警察彻底疯狂了。他们再次冲入人群。现在，他们第一次明确将一些组织者作为目标。所以有一个MOBE的组织者，一个叫雷尼·戴维斯的家伙。他们将他作为目标，把他按倒在地。一大群人把他打得失去知觉。到处都是血，他不得不被紧急送往医院。就在那时，他的朋友，一个叫汤姆·海登的家伙，他是美国最著名、或者曾经是最著名的学生领袖之一
been, he gets up and he gives this incredibly impassioned speech and he says to the crowd, let's turn this overheated military machine against itself. Let's make sure that if blood is going to flow, let it flow all over the city. If the police are going to run wild, let them run wild all over the city and not over us. If we're going to be disrupted and violated, let this whole stinking city be disrupted and violated. Find your way out of here. I will see you in the streets. So quite French Revolution. Very French Revolution, very Camus des Moulins, isn't it? At the Palais Royal. So at that point, the rally breaks up. It's unclear what they're going to do. There are different plans.
他站起来发表了一场极其慷慨激昂的演讲，他对人群说，让我们把这个过热的军事机器转向它自己。让我们确保如果要有血流，就让血流遍整个城市。如果警察要疯狂，就让他们在全城疯狂，而不是在我们身上。如果我们注定要被打碎和被侵犯，就让整个发臭的城市被打碎和被侵犯。找到你们的出路。我在街上等你们。所以很有法国大革命的感觉。非常法国大革命，非常像卡穆·德穆兰在皇家宫殿的表现，不是吗？所以在那个时候，集会解散了。目前还不清楚他们要做什么。有不同的计划。
There's about 6,000 people blocked in Grand Park and some of them sit down and start singing protest songs. The police start bringing up arrest fans and some of the crowds become very frightened and they want to get away into the streets, into the loop. They sort of start to head towards the bridges. There are railroad bridges that connect the park to the loop, to the downtown area. But as they get to the bridges, they find that most of them are blocked by lines of national guardsmen with machine guns. So they're trapped. They're trapped. I mean, it's a bit like, for the sake of argument, the Battle of Lake Trasimene, where the Romans
大约有6,000人被困在格兰特公园，其中一些人坐下来开始唱抗议歌曲。警察开始调来囚车，一些人群变得非常害怕，他们想逃到街上、逃进环形区。他们开始朝桥梁方向前进。有一些铁路桥将公园与环形区、市中心连接起来。但当他们到达桥边时，他们发现大部分桥都被架着机枪的国民警卫队防线封锁了。所以他们被困住了。他们被困住了。我的意思是，这有点像特拉西梅诺湖战役，当时罗马人
were trapped by Hannibal. Well Tom. What do you think you say? Just you say? Just clutching at a historical analogy. Yeah, but I know and you know that you're not the first person to have made that analogy and you'll come to the person who makes that analogy later. As darkness falls, the police start to wade into this trapped crowd with the clubs and stuff, but also firing tear gas grenades. So now you have people who are vomiting on the ground, crying, being blinded, whatever, and the police just whacking them over the heads. An atmosphere of total panic. And now you have tear gas drifting west from the park over the bridges towards the Democratic hotels on Michigan Avenue.
被汉尼拔困住了。好吧，汤姆。你觉得你在说什么？只是随口说说？只是抓住一个历史类比。是的，但我知道，你也知道，你并不是第一个做出这种类比的人，你稍后会遇到那个做出这种类比的人。随着夜幕降临，警察开始用警棍等武器冲进这群被困的人群，同时还发射催泪瓦斯手榴弹。所以现在有人在地上呕吐、哭泣、失明，诸如此类，而警察只是猛击他们的头部。一片彻底恐慌的气氛。现在催泪瓦斯从公园向西飘过桥梁，飘向密歇根大道上的民主党酒店。
Eventually the crowd finds one bridge that has been left unguarded, Jackson Drive. So for people who know Chicago, it's between the Art Institute and the Symphony Center. So it is right in the heart of kind of institutional Chicago. The crowd floods over the bridge onto Michigan Avenue and here they find a very bizarre sight. In front of them is a three wagon mule train that is being sort of shepherded along the street by Martin Luther King's friend, Ralph Abernathy. So people who listen to the Martin Luther King podcast will remember the Poor People's Campaign. Oh yeah.
最后，人群发现了一座无人看守的桥，杰克逊大道（Jackson Drive）。所以对于了解芝加哥的人来说，它在艺术学院和交响乐中心之间。所以它正处于芝加哥体制化市中心的核心。人群涌过桥，来到密歇根大道，在这里他们发现了一个非常诡异的景象。在他们面前是一列三辆车的骡队，正由马丁·路德·金的朋友拉尔夫·阿伯纳西（Ralph Abernathy）引导着沿街前行。所以听过马丁·路德·金播客的人会记得穷人运动。哦，是的。
You know, King's great project, right? Abernathy has brought this mule train to symbolize poverty with his wagons with mules. He's brought them to the center of Chicago, a very bizarre and incongruous sight. Yeah, because it must come as quite a surprise to yippies and police alike, I would imagine. Yeah. You've been shouting about like pigs and stuff. Suddenly it's a little house on the prairie. You've been tear gassed and then suddenly, exactly, run over the bridge and there it
你知道金的伟大计划，对吧？阿伯纳西带着这个骡队来象征贫困，拉着他的骡车。他把他们带到了芝加哥市中心，这是一个非常怪异和不合时宜的景象。是的，因为这一定让嬉皮士和警察都大吃一惊，我想象。是的。你们一直在大喊大叫像猪之类的话。突然间它成了草原上的小屋。你们刚被催泪瓦斯熏过，然后突然，没错，跑过桥，它就在那里。
is. And they do have a permit to go all the way down to the amphitheatre as a reminder to the delegates of poverty in the heart of America, right? And they're moving very slowly under police guard. So you have now this incredibly weird scene. There's about 6,000 to 7,000 people packed into the center of Chicago in the intersection of Balboa Drive and Michigan Avenue, literally underneath the multi-story Hilton Hotel, kind of a huge high-rise building.
他们确实有许可证一直走到露天剧场，作为对美国核心地带贫困问题的代表们的提醒，对吧？他们在大批警察的护卫下走得很慢。所以你现在有了这个极其怪异的场面。大约有6000到7000人挤在芝加哥市中心巴尔博亚大道（Balboa Drive）和密歇根大道的十字路口，字面意思就在多层希尔顿酒店的下方，那是一种巨大的高层建筑。
And they're chanting, dump the hump. There's these mules, they're surrounded by police. Tear gas. Tear gas. Eventually the police commanders agree to let the mule train through, but only the mule train. So the lions part and the mule train kind of proceeds off the stage towards the amphitheatre. Point successfully made, you'd say.
他们高呼：“赶走驼背（dump the hump）。”有这些骡子，它们被警察包围着。催泪瓦斯。催泪瓦斯。最终警察指挥官同意让骡队通过，但只能让骡队通过。于是人群让开一条路，骡队朝着露天剧场的方向走去。可以说，目的已经达到了。
I guess so. Well, they haven't quite got to the amphitheatre yet, but the police lions then reform and now the demonstrators are effectively surrounded again and basically it's about eight o'clock, whether there's a signal that is given or whether it is an improvised moment, it's impossible to be sure, but the police just go for it. They pile in as one into the crowd, screaming at abuse at the protesters. They've got their clubs, some of them are just using their fists, they're spraying mate in their faces. Some protesters fight back, they brought sticks and rocks in the park, but that only inflames
我想是吧。嗯，他们还没完全走到露天剧场，但警察防线随后重新组建，现在示威者实际上又被包围了，基本上大约是八点钟，无论是有人发出了信号还是这是一个即兴的时刻，无法确定，但警察就是上了。他们一窝蜂地冲进人群，向抗议者大喊大叫。他们拿着警棍，有些人只是用拳头，他们在人们脸上喷防狼喷雾。一些抗议者进行了反击，他们在公园里带来了棍棒和石头，但这只会激怒警察，让他们更加疯狂。
the cops further. More cops are being unloaded from buses of reinforcements. As they get off their buses, people see them and they're chanting, kill, kill, kill. And they pile into the demonstrators, they push a whole load of them back against the glass windows of these office blocks. The windows shatter and the demonstrators fall backwards into the buildings and then the police in on top of them among the shards of glass, kind of total and utter carnage. And this is the same time as Prague is being...
更多的警察从增援的公共汽车上卸下来。当他们下车时，人们看到他们并高呼：“杀，杀，杀。”他们冲进示威者中，把一大群人推向这些办公大楼的玻璃窗。窗户粉碎了，示威者向后跌入建筑物中，然后警察在玻璃碎片中踩着他们爬上去，这是一种完全彻底的屠杀。而这与布拉格正在……同时发生。
Yes, of course. Soviet tanks are coming in. So I think the protesters call it Chicago, Checargo. Right. Kind of drawing the parallels. And I suppose one of the ways in which that comparison, which seems, I mean, on the face of it grotesque is the fact that the TV cameras are in Chicago for the convention and can cover all this. Whereas in Prague, obviously there isn't that kind of live TV. Oh, absolutely. Absolutely. So because this is under the Humphrey and McCarthy headquarters, the cameras are already there. There are huge floodlights. So if you go onto YouTube to
是的，当然。苏联坦克正在开进来。所以我想抗议者称之为芝加哥，“切卡哥”（Checargo）。没错，某种程度上是在进行类比。我想那个比较在某种程度上——乍看之下显得非常怪诞——是因为电视摄像机正在芝加哥拍摄大会，并且可以报道这一切。而在布拉格，显然没有那种现场电视直播。哦，绝对的，绝对的。所以因为这是在汉弗莱和麦卡锡总部下方，摄像机已经在那里了。有巨大的泛光灯。所以如果你去YouTube上看这些场景，你会看到它非常明亮，对吧？因为它被电视弧光灯照亮，摄像师就在那里拍摄。而警察也在袭击摄像师、新闻摄影记者以及诸如此类的人，作为这场总体混乱的一部分。诺曼·梅勒正在他的酒店里观看这一幕。他在那里报道大会。警察像一把切入木头的电锯一样发起进攻，锯齿就是他们警棍的边缘。
see the scenes, you will see it's very bright, right? Because it's lit up by TV arc lights and the cameramen are there filming it. And the police are attacking the cameramen as well and press photographers and things as part of this general chaos. Norma Mailer is watching this from his hotel. He's there to cover the convention. The police attacked like a chainsaw cutting into wood, the teeth of the saw, the edge of their clubs.
他们像镰刀割草一样发起进攻，20到30名警察排成一排呈弧形挥舞，他们的警棍殴打着，示威者四处逃窜。这种情况没完没了地持续下去。有没有总统候选人在观看？我特意想到了尤金·麦卡锡，如果是这样的话，他们都在看。第二次布匿战争中的一个事件是否也像震撼我一样震撼了他？所以麦卡锡在23楼，他向窗外望去，他起初说，这太不可思议了。
They attacked like a scythe through grass, lines of 20 and 30 policemen striking out in an arc, their clubs beating, demonstrators fleeing. And this goes on and on and on. And are any of the presidential candidates watching? I'm thinking specifically of Eugene McCarthy and if so, they're all watching. Yeah. Does an incident from the second Punic war strike him as it has struck me? So McCarthy is up on the 23rd floor and he's looking out of his window and he says at first, it's incredible.
这看起来像布勒哲尔（Bruegel）的画。然后他对手下说，让我想起了特拉西梅内湖战役。你看。他后来实际上修改了这一点，汤姆。改成坎尼会战，对吧？改成坎尼会战，没错。那是一场更糟的大屠杀。现在的问题是，你觉得这很了不起，但实际上他的竞选团队对此感到惊恐。
It looks like a broigle. And then he says to his aides, reminds me of the battle of Lake Trasimede. There you go. Which he actually later amends Tom. To the battle of Cannae, doesn't he? To the battle of Cannae, exactly. Which even worse slaughter. Now the thing is that you think this is tremendous, but actually his campaign staff were horrified
他们认为这表明他的超然和冷漠，他太忙于思考布匿战争的类比，而实际上他本该，你知道，在哭泣或者……我认为这让他们显得很糟糕。显然，尽管你说了那么多，你并不与60年代末的气质融为一体，对吧？你更像尤金·麦卡锡。不，我认为当一个来自布匿战争的类比击中你时，它就是击中你了。你知道，你就顺其自然吧。
by this. They thought it showed his detachment and his aloofness, that he was too busy thinking about Punic War parallels and actually he should have been, you know, weeping or... I think that reflects badly on them. You're clearly, despite all your talk, you're not at one with the temperament of the late 60s, are you? You're more Eugene McCarthy like. No, I think that when a parallel from the Punic Wars hits you, it hits you. You know, you go with it.
也许吧。有时候人们不想听到来自布匿战争的类比，很显然。好吧，对他们来说。他的志愿者总部在15楼，后来变成了一个临时的受伤者医院。他们把抗议者带上来，麦卡锡确实下去看望了伤员，后来他的志愿者们去和示威者唱歌，并表达对他们的声援。休·汉弗莱则在更高的地方，他在25楼，他其实并没有观看这些场景，因为他受到了催泪瓦斯的波及。
Well, maybe. There are times when people don't want to hear a parallel from the Punic Wars, clearly. Well, for them. His volunteer headquarters, which was down on the 15th floor, was later turned into a makeshift hospital for the wounded. They brought up protesters and McCarthy did go down to visit the wounded and later on his volunteers went to sing songs with the demonstrators and expressed solidarity with them. Hubert Humphrey on the other hand, he's higher up, he's on the 25th floor and he's not watching these scenes actually because he has been affected by the tear gas which
好吧，也许吧。有时候人们就是不想听来自布匿战争的平行对比，很明显。好吧，对他们来说。他的志愿者总部位于15楼，后来被改造成了一个临时的伤员医院。他们把抗议者带了上去，麦卡锡确实亲自下楼去探望了伤员，后来他的志愿者们去和示威者一起唱歌，表达对他们的声援。另一方面，休伯特·汉弗莱则在更高的地方，他在25楼，他实际上并没有观看这些场景，因为他已经受到了催泪瓦斯的波及
has come up through the air conditioning. Unbelievable isn't it? And he has had to retire to the shower to basically try to wash out the tear gas and stuff. And that's why the story of 1968 is such an amazing one to tell, that throughout it, there are these unbelievably vivid metaphorical scenes that combine colour with the grotesque. Yeah, completely. Because, right, this has been happening on the very night that delegates are nominating their candidate for president. So the campaign, this incredibly dramatic campaign is reaching his climax at this moment. So at the amphitheatre, there are now three candidates. There is Humphrey, there is Eugene McCarthy, and there's also another senator from South
甚至弥漫到了空调系统里。难以置信，对吧？他不得不去浴室清洗身上的催泪瓦斯。这就是为什么1968年的故事如此引人入胜，在整个事件中，充满了这种将色彩与荒诞结合在一起的逼真隐喻场景。确实如此。因为就在代议士们提名总统候选人的当晚，这一切正在发生。因此，这场极具戏剧性的竞选活动在此时达到了高潮。在露天剧场里，现在有三位候选人。有汉弗莱，有尤金·麦卡锡，还有来自南
Dakota, George McGovern, a former historian, who has basically stepped forward to inherit Kennedy's delegates. So the front man for the Kennedy campaign. And the first footage of the fighting appears on network TV at about 9.30 that evening, and the delegates can't believe it. I mean, they're watching the cops in riot helmets just beating the living daylights out of defenseless people on the ground. And Senator Abraham Ribicoff is from Connecticut, has got up to the platform to nominate George McGovern for president. He's seen the scenes, he's heard the news, and it's an incredible moment if you watch
达科他州的另一位参议员乔治·麦戈文，他曾是一位历史学家，基本上是为了继承肯尼迪的代表支持而站出来，也就是肯尼迪竞选团队的前台人物。那天晚上大约九点半，冲突的第一批镜头出现在全国电视网的节目中，代表们简直不敢相信。我是说，他们看到戴着防暴头盔的警察正在暴打地上一群手无寸铁的人。来自康涅狄格州的参议员亚伯拉罕·里比科夫走上讲台，提名乔治·麦戈文竞选总统。他看到了这些场面，听到了这些消息，如果你观看
the footage. He looks directly at Mayor Daley and he says, with George McGovern as president of the United States, we wouldn't have to have Gestapo tactics in the streets of Chicago. And Daley in the Illinois delegation at that go completely berserk. At first, if you watch the footage, Daley clearly laughs contemptuously. And then it's as someone has flicked a switch and Daley loses it. And he shouts, you, you son of a, you lousy mother, go home. And there is total bedlam, right? And Ribicoff standing up there, cool, contemptuous, he stares at Daley in the face and he says,
这段画面，那真是一个令人难以置信的时刻。他直视着达利市长，说道：“只要有乔治·麦戈文担任美国总统，我们就不会在芝加哥街头看到盖世太保的战术。”达利和伊利诺伊州的代表团听后彻底暴怒。起初，如果你看这段录像，达利明显带着轻蔑地笑了。接着就像有人按下了开关，达利情绪失控了。他大喊：“你这个，你这个杂种，你这个令人作呕的混蛋，滚回家去。”现场一片彻底的混乱，对吧？而里比科夫站在那里，冷静而轻蔑，他直视着达利的脸说道：
how hard it is to accept the truth. How hard it is. I mean, an amazing scene to be playing out on national television. And you can imagine, I guess, that the Democrats spin doctors. I'm thinking this could be going better. Yes, it's not ideal for the Democrats of party's image. So Humphrey wins on the first ballot, massive margin. And Humphrey's come out of the shower now. He's in his hotel suite at the Hilton. So he can see.
“接受真相是多么艰难啊。多么艰难啊。”我的意思是，这是一个在全国电视直播中上演的惊人场景。你可以想象，民主党的公关策划们当时会觉得事情本可以进展得更顺利一些。是的，这对民主党的党派形象来说并非理想状态。所以汉弗莱在第一轮投票中以巨大优势获胜。汉弗莱现在洗完澡出来了，他住在希尔顿酒店的套房里，所以他能看到。
He can see he's watching the television surrounded by photographers to mark the moment. And because he's Mr. Cheerable, he just completely fails to kind of grasp the mood. So his wife's face appears on the screen. She's down at the convention at the moment that he wins. And he says, Oh, how pretty you are. I wish you were here with me now. And he kneels down and kisses the television screen with her face on it. And photographers take pictures of this. Now it's a very sweet moment in one sense, but for him to be doing that, well, down below, there's this police riot, glass, tear gas. You could say that he is conjuring up the warmth of the traditional American way.
他看到自己正在看电视，周围挤满了记录这一时刻的摄影记者。由于他是个“开心果”，他完全没有体会到当时的氛围。这时他妻子的脸出现在屏幕上，那是她在他获胜时在大会现场的画面。他说：“哦，你多漂亮啊。我真希望你现在能陪在我身边。”然后他跪下来，吻了吻印有她脸庞的电视屏幕。摄影记者们拍下了这一幕。从某种意义上说，这这是一个非常温馨的时刻，但在他这样做的时候，楼下却正在发生警察暴动、玻璃破碎、催泪瓦斯弥漫。可以说，他在唤起传统美国生活方式的温情。
Well, you could, yeah. Apple pie, all that kind of thing. Of course you could. Which I guess it will be his pitch, won't it? When it comes to actually running for the presidency. Yeah, but that pitch is totally drowned out. Yeah, I get it. I get it.
嗯，你也可以这么说。苹果派，诸如此类的事。当然可以。我想这也会成为他的竞选基调吧？当他真正参加总统竞选的时候。是的，但这种基调完全被淹没了。是的，我明白。我明白。
I'm just trying to stick up for him. I quite like him. I like him. I feel sorry for him. The next morning, you know, in the breakfast news, which everybody watches, NBC led with, they did a montage and they intercut scenes of Humphrey's delegates, Humphrey's supporters cheering and laughing and singing. They intercut it with footage of demonstrators being gassed and being beaten up on Michigan Avenue. The two things had not actually happened
我只是在替他说话。我挺喜欢他的。我喜欢他，我为他感到遗憾。第二天早上，大家都看的早间新闻里，全国广播公司（NBC）的头条是一段蒙太奇剪辑，他们将汉弗莱的代表和支持者们欢呼、大笑、唱歌的画面，与密歇根大道上示威者遭催泪瓦斯袭击和殴打的画面穿插在一起。这两件事实际上并没有
simultaneously. Their beatings had happened much earlier, but the TV networks gave the impression they had happened at the same time. And that was unbelievably bad publicity for Humphrey. Mayor Daley went ballistic. He went on CBS and he said to Walter Cronkite, we were fighting terrorists. He says, I had intelligence that they were planning to assassinate the democratic candidates. We've had three people shot in the last few years. No, it's not true.
同时发生。殴打事件发生得要早得多，但电视网给人的印象是它们同时发生了。这对于汉弗莱来说是难以置信的糟糕宣传。达利市长气急败坏。他在哥伦比亚广播公司（CBS）对沃尔特·克朗凯特说：“我们在与恐怖分子战斗。”他说：“我有情报显示他们计划暗杀民主党候选人。过去几年我们已经有三个人被枪杀。”不，这不是真的。
You've made that up. The trouble is the Yippies have said so many incendiary stuff. Lurid and sensationist things. It's hard for anybody to be certain who doesn't understand. It's easy for us. We know that the Yippies are all about dope and about talking nonsense. And there had been lots of assassinations. So there have been assassinations. Yeah. McCarthy that afternoon went and talked to demonstrators in the park. He said, you're the government in exile. And he read them a nice poem.
那是你编造的。问题是嬉皮士们说了太多煽动性的话，那些耸人听闻的言论。对于不了解情况的人来说，很难确定什么是真的。对我们来说很简单，我们知道嬉皮士们整天只想着吸毒和胡说八道。而且当时确实发生过很多暗杀事件，所以确实有过暗杀。是的。那天下午，麦卡锡去公园里和示威者交谈。他说：“你们是流亡政府。”他还给他们读了一首好诗。
That's quite yippee, isn't it? Well, it was a poem by his friend Robert Lowell, who is this kind of very kind of New England, Harvard kind of poet. Yeah, of course. Tweed. Yeah, very Tweed. Very Tweed. Not the vibe.
这挺有嬉皮士风格的，不是吗？嗯，那是他的朋友罗伯特·洛厄尔的一首诗，他是一个典型的充满新英格兰和哈佛风格的诗人。是的，当然。粗花呢风格。是的，非常粗花呢。非常粗花呢。不太符合这种氛围。
Not quite the vibe. But I think, you know, if you like poetry, it's nice to have some on the show. That evening is Hubert Humphrey's moment. So he finally gets to make his speech. You could not imagine worse circumstances to make your speech in. He starts his speech by talking about his sadness at the violence. He doesn't really do sadness.
不太符合这种氛围。但我觉得，如果你喜欢诗歌，节目里有点诗歌挺好的。那天晚上是休伯特·汉弗莱的高光时刻。他终于可以发表演讲了。你简直无法想象还有比这更糟糕的环境来发表演讲了。他在演讲一开始就表达了对暴力的痛心。他其实并不擅长表现悲伤。
So when he first announced his candidacy, he had said he was going to bring back the politics of happiness and the politics of joy. But obviously he can't play that card now. He has to look sad and sombre. He actually, I hadn't realized this until a couple of days ago, he does a Margaret Thatcher. He reads the, where there is discord, may we bring harmony? He reads that so-called St Francis of Assisi prayer, which St Francis of Assisi never said, but he doesn't use a good translation.
所以当他最初宣布参选时，他说他要带回幸福的政治和快乐的政治。但显然他现在不能打这张牌了。他必须显得悲伤和凝重。事实上，直到几天前我才意识到这一点，他来了一出“玛格丽特·撒切尔”式的表演。他宣读了那段“哪里有不和谐，就让我们带来和谐”的话。他宣读了所谓阿西西的圣弗朗西斯的祈祷文，虽然阿西西的圣弗朗西斯从未说过这话，而且他用的翻译也不太好。
So it's not as powerful. And also he doesn't do a good Margaret Thatcher impersonation as I do. So a further disappointment for the Democrat delegates. Yeah, that's the real disappointment for the Democrats this week. But anyway, it's been a complete and utter nightmare for the Democrats. It confirms every suspicion that they are the party of chaos, the party of disorder, they are disunited. You know, the images that all Americans take from this convention are of violence and people screaming and sobbing in the streets and so on and so forth. The interesting thing though, Tom, I know you'll say this is a Sanbrook bingo point.
所以它并没有那么有力量。而且他模仿玛格丽特·撒切尔也没有我模仿得好。这对民主党代表来说是又一次失望。是的，这才是本周民主党人真正的失望所在。不管怎样，对民主党人来说，这是一个彻底的噩梦。它证实了人们所有的怀疑，即他们是混乱之党、无序之党，他们是不团结的。你知道，所有美国人从这次大会中留下的印象都是暴力、人们在街头尖叫和哭泣等等。不过有趣的是，汤姆，我知道你会说这是一个桑布鲁克宾果时刻。
Yeah, I do. I know exactly what you're going to say. The public side overwhelmingly with the police, not with the demonstrators. So Daley had a hundred thousand letters of support and 5,000 letters of criticism. And the polls showed that only 10% of the public thought the police were too harsh and more than double that thought they weren't harsh enough, which is kind of unsurprising, I guess. Well, I mean, so just to ask, to what extent were the public aware of where the yippies were coming from? I mean, had any of this kind of joyous, ludic riot banter, had it filtered through at all? Probably not massively.
是的，我确实会这么说。我知道你接下来要说什么。公众压倒性地站在警察一边，而不是示威者一边。所以达利收到了十万封支持信和五千封批评信。民意调查显示，只有10%的公众认为警察手段过于严厉，而持相反观点的比例是前者的两倍多，他们认为警察手段还不够严厉，这其实也在意料之中吧。嗯，我的意思是，我想问的是，公众在多大程度上了解嬉皮士们的立场？我是说，这种充满欢乐、嬉闹的暴动调侃，哪怕一点点，有没有渗透进去？可能没有多少。
In their minds, I think, if you're not somebody who massively follows the news, you turn on your TV and you see... And there's a bloke with long hair like a girl. But having the living daylights beaten out of him by the Chicago police, and you're shocked by the violence, but probably there are a lot of people, we know there are a lot of people who say, yeah, I don't like to see it, but what do they expect? Okay, but why?
在他们的心目中，我想，如果你不是那种狂热关注新闻的人，你打开电视就会看到……有个家伙留着像女孩一样长发的人，被芝加哥警察往死里打。你对这种暴力感到震惊，但可能很多人——我们知道有很多人——会说：“是的，我不想看到这种事，但他们还能期望什么呢？”好吧，但为什么呢？
Because the violence is so extreme. I don't see what it is about the yippies or the protesters or whatever that is so offensive that people would say, oh, well, they've had it coming. I think because it comes in a climate of a year that is to a lot of people very frightening and very disorderly, right? Assassinations, urban riots. So there's a backlash mood. There is a law and order mood. So like the people pulling down the American flag or dressing up as the Viet Cong or whatever, is this cutting through? I mean, are they being seen as completely unpatriotic? Undoubtedly. Okay. So that does cut through. Absolutely. That has cut through. So there is a sense certainly from 1967, I would say onwards,
因为暴力太极端了。我不明白嬉皮士、抗议者或者其他什么人有什么地方如此令人反感，以至于人们会说：“哦，好吧，这是他们自找的。”我想这是因为这发生在一个对许多人来说非常可怕且充满混乱的年份的背景下，对吧？暗杀、城市骚乱。所以有一种强烈反弹的情绪。有一种对法律与秩序的诉求。所以就像人们扯下美国国旗或者扮成越共之类的，这些行为产生影响了吗？我是说，他们被视为完全不爱国吗？毫无疑问。好吧。所以这确实产生了影响。绝对产生了。这确实产生了影响。因此，毫无疑问，从1967年开始，我可以这么说，
that the peace protesters are people who burn American flags, that they are long haired, that they take drugs. A lot of this may be very unfair, you know, and there are people in the peace movement who are very conscious of this and say, this is media distortion and actually there are parts of our movement that don't do our movement a great deal of good because the levitating the Pentagon and chanting songs and stuff. So there are still Quakers and stuff. Yeah, there are still people who say, come on, the point is to win over middle America and we are not doing that.
和平抗议者被视为焚烧美国国旗的人，他们留着长发，他们吸毒。其中很多可能很不公平，你知道，和平运动中也有人非常清楚这一点，并说这是媒体的扭曲，实际上我们运动中的某些部分对我们的运动并没有多大好处，比如五角大楼的悬浮抗议、吟唱颂歌之类的事情。所以当时还有贵格会教徒之类的人。是的，仍然有人说：“拜局所赐，关键是要争取到美国中部普通民众的支持，而我们并没有做到这一点。”
But the mood of the moment is wave a Viet Cong flag, chant ho ho ho chi min. So here's the thing, right? Imagine you are from a middle America community in Iowa or somewhere. And you know, boys who've gone off to fight in the Vietnam war. And then you turn on your telly. Long haired college kids. Chanting the names of the opposition. I think that's the problem. I mean, this is actually a moment you could argue from which all subsequent protest movements either have learned or should have learned. Yeah. I mean, it's the founding moment, isn't it? Yeah, absolutely. It's what you
但当时的氛围就是挥舞越共旗帜，高呼“胡志明万岁”。所以问题是，想象一下，如果你来自艾奥瓦州或某个地方的美国中部普通社区。你知道那些去越南战场参战的男孩们。然后你打开电视。留着长发的大学生成员高喊着敌方领导人的名字。我想这就是问题所在。我的意思是，这实际上是一个你可以说是所有后来的抗议运动要么已经从中吸取了教训、要么本应从中吸取教训的时刻。是的。我的意思是，这是一个开创性的时刻，不是吗？是的，绝对是。这就是你
do. The contrast is obviously with the civil rights movement earlier in the decade where they wear suits, they work really hard and it's not an accident they do it self-consciously. Martin Luther King and his allies think really carefully about how to appeal to, as it were, the silent majority, the broad mass of the American people. I don't think Abbie Hoffman and Jerry Rubin, the broad mass of the American people. I don't think Abbie Hoffman and Jerry Rubin gave the broad mass of the American people any thought whatsoever. Because they despise them. I guess so. Yeah. I mean, the civil rights movement shares, you know, they share Christianity with the vast mass of the American people. Yeah. But the peace protesters, I mean, despise all of that. They want to burn it all down. Yeah. Let's try out the story. Seven people were charged by a grand jury in the
所做的事。这显然与本年代早期的民权运动形成了鲜明对比，当时他们穿着西装，工作非常努力，这不是偶然，而是他们刻意为之的。马丁·路德·金和他的盟友们深思熟虑地考虑了如何吸引所谓的“沉默的大多数”，即广大美国普通民众。我不认为阿比·霍夫曼和杰里·鲁宾曾为广大美国普通民众考虑过哪怕一秒钟。因为他们鄙视他们。我想是的。是的。我的意思是，民权运动与广大美国民众分享了……你知道，他们拥有共同的基督教信仰。是的。但和平抗议者，我是说，鄙视这一切。他们想把这一切都烧毁。好吧，让我们说说这个故事。有七人被一个大陪审团起诉，
US District Court for Illinois with using interstate commerce with intent to incite a riot. And these were the so-called Chicago Seven. So Abbie Hoffman and Jerry Rubin, Bobby Seale of the Black Panthers, though he was later, he was declared a mistrial, Dave Dellinger, Tom Haidt and Renny Davis and so on and so forth. And they turned the trials in 1969 into kind of political showpieces, denouncing the judge or this kind of thing. They were acquitted of the conspiracy charge, but then convicted of other offenses. They did spend time in prison, but those convictions were eventually reversed on appeal. So that is the story of the Chicago seven, which was a kind of Netflix
地点是伊利诺伊州美国地区法院，罪名是利用州际商业意图煽动暴乱。这就是所谓的“芝加哥七君子”。其中包括阿比·霍夫曼、杰里·鲁宾、黑豹党的鲍比·西尔（尽管他后来被宣告审判无效）、戴夫·德林格、汤姆·海登和雷尼·戴维斯等等。他们在1969年的审判中把法庭变成了一种政治作秀，谴责法官之类的事情。他们被判谋杀同谋罪名不成立，但被判犯有其他罪行。他们确实在监狱里度过了一段时间，但这些定罪最终在高等法院上诉时被推翻。这就是“芝加哥七君子”的故事，这曾被拍成网飞电影
or something. There's a film. Yeah. Good film. Theo must have seen it because he was absolutely bleeding hearted, about half time shocked that we were given the police's point of view. But back to the story of the politics of 68. Hubert Humphrey, now nominated, leaves Chicago in absolute despair. I mean, he said later he felt that politics had become polluted and destroyed in the course of the year.
或其他什么平台的作品。有一部电影。是的，好电影。西奥肯定看过，因为他在中场休息时表现得极其悲天悯人，对我们展现警察的视角感到震惊。但回到68年政治的故事上来。休伯特·汉弗莱如今被正式提名，带着极度的绝望离开了芝加哥。我的意思是，他后来曾说，他觉得政治在这一年里已经被污染和毁灭了。
He'd been very offended, hadn't he, by the bad language used in front of ladies? Yes. I think rightly. I don't agree with using bad language in front of ladies myself. So he is trapped. He is totally trapped, poor Humphrey, by his fealty to Johnson and to the war. He feels he can't break with the president and he can't break with the administration's policy, but how else can he possibly bring his party together?
他一定对在女士面前使用粗俗语言感到非常冒犯，不是吗？是的。我想他是对的。我自己也不赞成在女士面前说脏话。所以他被困住了，可怜的汉弗莱完全被他对约翰逊和对越战的忠诚所困。他觉得他不能与总统决裂，也不能与政府的政策决裂，但他还能怎么做才能把他的党派团结起来呢？
However, the one thing I should say about Humphrey, all his life he has been a fighter, you know, he's a hardened campaigner and the one thing that can possibly bring his party together, I guess, is that they are facing their ultimate bogeyman, the one politician whom most Democrats despise more than any other. And that's the man we'll be discussing in the final episode of this series as we turn to the great winner of this epic story, Richard Milhouse Nixon. Okay, Dominic, thanks very much. And if you want to hear it straight away, you can do that, you know, the routine by going to therestishistory.com and signing up to the club there. But either way, we will be back very soon with the climax of America 1968. Goodbye.
然而，关于汉弗莱，我必须指出的一点是，他一生都是个斗士，你知道，他是一个身经百战的竞选人，而唯一可能让他的党派团结起来的事情，我想，就是他们面临着终极的眼中钉——那个大多数民主党人比任何人都更鄙视的政客。这就是我们在本系列最后一集中要讨论的人，我们将迎来这个史诗故事的伟大胜利者——理查德·米尔豪斯·尼克松。好的，多米尼克，非常感谢。如果你想立刻收听，你知道老规矩，可以访问 therestishistory.com 并注册成为俱乐部的会员。无论如何，我们很快就会回来，为大家带来《1968年的美国》的高潮部分。再见。
Goodbye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。该集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。